this is a planning meeting with public
participation not a public meeting
therefore only persons registered to
speak will be allowed to do so during
the evening we will be webcast so it's a
big wide world if you don't wish to be
seen on that please let them know the
appropriate time there are no fire alarm
scheduled this evening that I'm aware of
so if you do hear an alarm it is a
genuine one if you make your way out to
the main entrance down is the car park
by the side that windmill pub not in the
pub by the side of it thank you
right the items before us as you'll see
there are some update sheets for
late-breaking news members have you had
an opportunity to look through those
thank you otherwise I think we'll just
get on I'd like the officers to
introduce themselves starting from my
right place Caroline Nash committee
administrator Rox chambers legal
services can Tate committee manager
contain a young senior planner
thank you the we'll move into the agenda
and first of all apologies for absence
apologies receive from accounts of
ordering counts for Richard for whom
cats the fielding is substituting and
thank you very much indeed for doing
that councillor disclosures of interest
members council pain
Thank You Ann Ann that particular point
because I'm also predetermine long that
I'll be signing down on that item Thank
You counsel coach yeah I've had I think
correspondence in i25 Oh No yeah I think
I have five till engine Road and item
ten Middletown and I've spoken to the
applicant from Middletown but I haven't
determined so I shall sit in I think
we've all received some notification
from the thank you
Thank You chair yeah um I some four yeah
seventeen oblique zero to five light
very this is a little I'm not I should
be speaking against this as parish
council chairman thank you very much
okay the procedure for this evenings
items is as follows the officer will do
a introduction on the item will then go
through the speakers that will be the
parish and Town Council's objectors and
applicants he will give them three
minutes normally unless they are there
are two speakers in which case you get a
commission time of 6 minutes then the
ward member is allowed to speak for up
to 5 minutes we then go into technical
items with the officer and then to
debate and then we will take a vote on
this members you forward proceed just
for a smoothness of proceedings for the
item that I will be standing down on we
will obviously have to nominate a chair
I would like to nominate council Lawton
do I have a seconder for that thank you
very much indeed
all those in favor thank you very much
indeed
right thank you very much indeed for
those right our first item on the agenda
this evening ven is 17 / 172 9 / 4 and
17 / / 1 7 3 0 / LPC 38 to 39 waterside
stratford-upon-avon over to Alice Thank
You chairman as members will be aware a
site visit took place this afternoon
councillors Cargill fielding and Lawton
were in attendance the application site
which is noted by the black dot in the
centre as the plan is located in the
town centre of Stratford on Avon the
site which is outlined in red is located
on the corner of waterside and Charlayne
it comprises the RSC costume workshop
and chaplain offices the costume
workshop is currently operated from the
scene dock building and barn which are
both grade 2 listed buildings as well as
from modern additions which extend
between them and the chapel Lane offices
the building's coloured red on the plan
denote listed buildings as is apparent
from the plan a number of grade 2 listed
buildings are joined the site as well as
the grade 2 stylist at Royal Shakespeare
and Swan theatre being located to the
other side of waterside here the
existing site plan can be seen with
waterside to the bottom of the slide and
chapel lane to the left-hand side of the
slide annotation on the plan clarifies
the location of the scene dock building
and barn with more modern additions
extending off them for planning
permission and listed building consent
is sought for the renovation and part
redevelopment of the costume workshop to
provide improved workshops and offices
for the RSC this would comprise
alterations to the great relisted scene
dock building and barn as well as the
demolition of a range of modern
additions and their replacement with one
and two-story extensions to include a
green roof link to the existing Chaplin
offices to the rear of the site the
elevation at the top of this slide shows
how the proposed extensions were
protrude above the roofs of the listed
buildings which front onto waterside the
bottom elevation shows the same view of
the building but as a section through
the scene dock building the gray areas
of the elevations would be constructed
in red brick with the stripes indicating
areas of breeze fillet
the elevation at the top of the slide
shows the proposed extensions from
chapel lane with the bottom elevation
showing the elevation behind the
cottages which front onto chapel Lane
the pitched roofs would be finished with
slate
this shows the northern elevation with
waterside on the left-hand side of the
slide and the existing Chapel Lane
offices on the right-hand side and this
shows elevation facing the chapel Lane
offices to the rear of the site the
white rectangle denotes the section
which has been taken through the green
roof link from the extension to the
existing Chapel Lane offices this photo
shows the view of the site from
waterside the gray 2 listed scene stop
building is annotated with a listed barn
and modern additions toward the rear of
the cottages which can be seen in this
photo and this is taken from Chapel Lane
the existing RSC offices can be seen on
the left-hand side of the slide with the
rear elevation of the scene dot building
just visible in the center of the photo
the Royal Shakespeare and Swan theatres
can be seen on the right hand side of
the slide and just to take you through a
food photos as taken from the theatre
tower so my cursor isn't working if I
just come out of there a moment so you
can see here is the scene dock building
the listed barn and the modern additions
to be demolished similarly you can see
the scene stop building the barn and the
modern positions to be demolished here
and then another pan around photo
members should note that there are
update to the application which is
detailed within the update sheet
chairman the recommendation is to
approve both applications for planning
permission annalistic building consent
as per the recommendations are set out
in the committee reports and the
conditions detailed thank you thank you
our speakers this evening applicants
which is Catherine million Steven ribbit
and greedy Davis
thank you you have three minutes in your
own time
I'll give a 30-second warning
approximately before we go yes don't get
too close to microphone to speak clearly
thank you
there enjoyed by millions of people
across the world every year and they
play a crucial part in helping actors
create their characters and costume
making here has a very long history the
thirty cross people who work on-site
cover every specialist costume making
skill they also maintain all the
costumes during the life of the show
which is why proximity to the theater is
essential the extremely cramped costume
workshop accommodation that poor
ventilation and temperature control
limited daylight insufficient storage
floor levels that do not match narrow
passageways low beams causing hazards
type need eight stairs and there is no
lift it's not an accessible building in
any way the constraints of the working
conditions caused a range of health and
safety issues they severely restrict our
ability to develop our processes and
prevent us teaching craft skills to the
next generation of costume makers
overall the workshop is not fit for
purpose our proposal for the restoration
and redevelopment of the costume
workshop has four clear aims costume
making in the heart of
stratford-upon-avon to care for the
important heritage buildings including
the 1887 scene door which will become a
new entrance to the RFC's offices
thirdly to create new training and
apprenticeship opportunities and secure
the future of costume making in the town
and finally to enable visitors for the
first time to experience our workshop
through tours and online developing the
scheme
and it's location in conservation area
we acknowledge the proximity of the
workshop to the surrounding residential
properties it also include the and we're
consulting closely with everyone we have
also undertaken extensive application
specialist dialogue and responded to all
recommendations we also minimize
disruption from okay try to achieve them
you may do that last little bit again if
you wish to thank you very much indeed
members there are any questions you
would like to ask castafiore just a
quick one with regards to flood barriers
that have been tested on along the
riverbanks have you taken any
precautions with regards to flooding
that may may occur not detail work in
that area I might ask Greek to talk to
that
oh my word yes advice has been taken as
part of as part of the design and the
design has considered where certain
elements are to be situated within
within the workshop space the front area
are seen as part of your worker walk
around today is the area potentially at
most risk however falls within the one
in a floodplain so we've taken advice
we've consulted we've taken flood risk
assessments and we feel confident that
how we've designed it will address it
sorry may I ask a question obviously
having been around the facility
I do appreciate how constrained is new
and also I think you have some very
valued workers local people working
there would you envisage perhaps at this
facility expanding in any way with the
new development and we will be doing
that yeah we're planning on introducing
initially to 20 2021 and thereafter
continuing with to start with hopefully
we'll will increase because there are
within the costume departments there are
quite a few departments
to shoemaking as well as yes it's quite
diverse councillor Lordan Thank You
chair um yes I thoroughly enjoyed our
road trip round this afternoon I agree
with the chairman though the facilities
there are medieval Victorian um one
thing that's interesting and perhaps
members might like to know is what the
proposals are for a general public
access to the new facility and how you
see that working there's a wide range of
public access activities from to see the
dilemma is of course the costumes but
we've devised a route around the new
space that will allow public to look
into the workshops while the work is
taking place we've also got various
interactive virtual reality plans to
install within within the ballistic barn
there which is going to be a multi-user
space for the start of tours for talks
or lectures with the Education
Department will be bringing students in
to talk about the art of costume making
so we've got quite a quite an extensive
plan for interactive and it will become
part of the RSC thank you any other
questions members it's a pedestrian
access largely for the staff to take
costumes to and from the theatre in fact
rather than coming through the the
reception area but it's largely to get
to get costumes from
thank you thank you very much indeed if
you could just turn your microphones off
thank you all right
that's council friendly did you wish to
speak your the ward member yes thank you
you can you can yes thank you very much
very very briefly at ward member I
completely and thoroughly support this
application well Jenny that was fast
thank you no questions okay are there
any technical questions you would like
to ask this council jars and then cares
about I'm just looking at one paragraph
on page 13 I suppose what I'm trying to
get is a sense from waterside and
particularly Bancroft Gardens to what
degree the built form is going to be
visible from street level behind that
because you know I haven't got any sort
of heights or anything so I just sort of
can't get a sense of to what degree it's
going to be visible I do actually have a
visualization which has been provided by
the architects so let me just show you
that and hopefully that will give you a
good indication so for me that bit
larger so these are basically the gable
dens that you'd see from those
elevations similarly on the other side
the gables would protrude in a similar
fashion but obviously you'd never get
far enough back to be able to see it
based on like in the elevation because
of the theater being so close but
hopefully that gives you some
understanding as to how it would look
under the materials in that
visualization pretty accurate in terms
of what we're going to be looking at
yeah absolutely so Gables would be
largely redbrick we've actually had a
sample in but we've conditioned a sample
panel as well just to confirm water and
it was average of red brick we we're
satisfied that it's very typical in
terms of what's in the in the area
no questions Thank You chairman um Alice
that's great that visualization that's
that's perfect is the one provided by
the architect for the visualization
looking from chapel lane if you could be
just a little bit confused about what I
was looking at during your presentation
I'm sorry so you've got the RSC chaplain
offices here so these are the cottages
which fronts on to Chapel Lane and Bend
around the corner onto waterside so
these are basically the roofs which you
would see over the top of the cottages
again because you can't step back far
enough a'dope you would never see at
that exact angle obviously you would see
it coming this way down Chapel Lane but
I don't have I have the rear elevation
but I don't have that sort of angled
view or visualization from from the
architects taught me to pull up I wasn't
quite sure where where I'm looking at
okay when I'm looking at that where am i
standing so here you're essentially
standing in the middle of the chapel
Lane offices so you've got the single
storey link from the proposed extension
into the chaplain offices so if we're
standing here we're looking towards
waterside beyond the building so at the
back of that you've basically got the
Royal Shakespeare Theatre in the
background but it's not shown oh we've
just got the elevation of see that's
what I couldn't quite I would have
thought it's taken an awful lot of hard
work to come up with such a good and
sensitive proposal in such a constrained
sight it clearly has a huge public
benefit and I'm very happy to support it
and would propose a grant thank you
cassabaum scatter character yes I'm very
happy to second it and what I can gather
room
because they closed all the roads so
flooding won't be a problem there and
say a lot of work going into it and it's
what we needed him I'm happy thank you
well I should just say also from my
perspective having seen it and castle
Orton did make the comparison between
the jewelry court and it is an old
fashioned building not that the purpose
was mentioned by the applicants and not
for the modern age as well to attract
young new designers and costume Music
Center so I think it's a really powerful
yes member just to remind you that there
are two votes this evening the first one
is on 1701 72 9/4 and then 17 3 0 l bc
so i have a proposal a seconder for the
first item will take the vote on that
one members to vote before use to grant
a planning permission for 17 / 0 1 7 2
knives / fault all those in favor
that's unanimous chairman and do I have
a proposer in fact I'll propose the 1701
seven-30 such LBC do I have a seconder
council fielding all those in favor
that's unanimous again thank you this
committee therefore resource to pass on
Planning Commission for 17 / / 1 7 29 /
4 + 17 / / 1 7 3 0 obviously thank you
very much indeed
right thank you next item on the agenda
again this is Alice it's a 17 - oh one
474 such full and it is 78 tootington
Road Stratton on Aven I do not have an
perished
speakers the first person three if you'd
like to be short-circuited you they
didn't like you carry on carry on Thank
You chairman members will be aware that
member site visit took place this
afternoon again councilors Cargill
building and Lawton were in attendance
the application site is denoted by the
black dot in the center of the plan and
is located on sitting term Road within
the built-up area boundary of strapped
on even the application site as outlined
in red comprises the dwelling of number
78 giving to Road and it's residential
curtilage the site is located within the
Conservation Area and disturbed by an
existing vehicle access off telling Jim
Road the existing dwelling is located
within a generous plot setback from the
main public highway with mature soft
planting along its front boundary it is
a traditional design being a pitched
roof construction and finished in render
and tile planning permission is sought
for a replacement dwelling and
associated detached outbuilding to the
rear of the site the dwelling would
provide parking gym and swimming pool at
basement level with habitable
accommodation at both grounds and
first-floor levels the proposed dwelling
would be served by the existing vehicle
access to the site the application forms
a resubmission of a scheme which
committee previously refused and which
was subsequently dismissed at appeal
this slide shows a comparison in the
site plans with the proposed site plan
at the top of the slide and previously
refused site plan at the bottom of the
slide members will know that the
single-story rear-projection
adjacent to the shared boundary with
number ata has been removed whilst the
forward projecting garage has been
enlarged the width of the dwelling has
also been reduced the contemporary
building would feature varying frontages
and
Heights finished in light and dark
brickwork the pitched roofs we finished
with zinc whilst the flat roofs elements
will be finished with green roofs here
you can see the proposed forensic
elevation at the top of the slide and
the previously refused front elevation
to the bottom of the slide
similarly the rear elevation is proposed
at the top with the previously refused
rear elevation at the bottom and here
are the proposed side elevations in the
context of the previously refused scheme
the detached outbuilding located at the
end of the garden would reflect the
design of the replacement dwelling and
would be used as a garden store the
architect has submitted this
visualization to give more of a flavour
of the proposed dwelling on this slide
you can see photos of the front and rear
elevations of the existing dwelling
looking down Teddington Road in a
southwesterly direction the neighboring
property of number 88 can be seen on the
left-hand side of the slide with the
side wall and front gables of the
existing dwelling visible visible
through the trees and boundary planting
the existing dwelling and its associated
vehicular access as viewed from the main
public highway and looking down to the
Newton Road in an easterly direction the
neighboring property of number 76 can be
seen on the right-hand side of the slide
with the existing dwelling which
occupies the application site behind the
trees and boundary hedging members
should note that there are a couple of
updates as detailed on the update sheet
chairman the recommendation is to
approve the application subject
conditions as detailed within the
committee report thank you thank you
just on that particular point on the
update sheet one additional letter
received in CPR
I think you've addressed that particular
yes oh just confirmed that was a point
of clarification on their original
comments which are proceed in the
committee report thank you very much
okay our first speaker is Peter Phillips
Phipps
it's even written down correctly I
didn't get it right mr. Phipps you have
three minutes in your own time okay
thank you very much firstly marys thank
you for the site visit this afternoon
I'm also speaking on behalf of mr. and
mrs. Thomas of 76 didn't in road
unfortunately they can't be here this
evening right minutes sorry the images
on the screen show the existing
habitable house and the footprint of the
existing and the proposed house two
similar applications have been refused
by this committee the last one
unanimously an appeal has also been
dismissed by the inspect on the grounds
of mass bulk scale and the significant
harm to heritage asset the inspector
stated the development would fail and
failed to preserve and enhance the
character and appearance of the
conservation area and any such harm
should be avoided he noted that the
appellant had promoted high quality
design as a public benefit however the
inspector disagreed and said this did
not outweigh the harm he had identified
he found the development conflicted with
policy cs8 this new development is still
significantly larger visibly intrusive
and overbearing and dominance the seven
metre high flat roofs still remain it
again fails to reflect the character and
distinctiveness of the locality yes the
width has been reduced the pool moved
and some pitch roofs introduced but
despite two meetings with the architect
the important concerns raised by the
inspector neighbors and the residents
Association also historic England have
been ignored the case officers decision
to approve the application is subjective
with no real evidence apart from her
belief that it is a high quality design
however these are the facts the proposed
ruling goes 53 feet deeper into the rear
garden than the existing the basement
garages 6,500 square feet 5,000 tons of
so will have to remove be removed to
accommodate this alone with the loss of
trees
the ground floor area is seven thousand
square feet this is 90
percent bigger than the existing the
first floor area is 4,000 square feet
a-hunting need 11% bigger the materials
to be used are foreign no other houses
in the conservation area have these
finishes they are not in keeping with
our conservation area the roof is zinc
the garden store is a thousand square
feet and 13 feet high this is no
standard garden shed at the last
committee meeting counselor courage
asked a clarification on CS 20 C and the
definition of not visibly intrusive he
asked whether the term applied only to
the street scene all the neighboring
properties and their gardens richard
garden at the planning manager confirmed
it applied equally to both in short the
dwelling is significantly larger extends
53 feet further into the rear garden and
is visibly intrusive to us neighbors it
fails to preserve the character and
fails to preserve the character of the
conservation area and his contract
country's policies of CSA series 9
series 20 the neighborhood development
plan policies H 5 and B 11 and the NPP F
y have planning laws and policies if
they are not going to be a dear to we
urge you to refuse this application once
again thank you very much this is a
matrix of areas compared with the
existing but the next slide if I may
shows the low level Sun at the end of
November it goes lower in December we
will lose this sunlight into our kitchen
you must just see the kitchen door
handle on the year the bottom right hand
corner there the development the 53 feet
goes right past where the Sun is and
raging see the washing line so
unfortunately we all lose that should
this development go ahead cuz it's so
tall I think thankfully clarification on
those right
just want to ask you brought material is
it because you've raised that it's in
the office report just to do is for
example with a brick it said because
it's a white brick and the darker brick
is on the side that actually in some
respects that even though it's obviously
not identical material it does for
example reflect some of the white render
that's visible on that Street what would
you say about that I agree with you but
they're not bricks they're like I
believe that I'm sure the architect will
correct me if I'm wrong they're more
like slate and they're different colors
there's white render one of the gables
is going to be dark black which the case
officer has said in her report that they
need to be looked at and the roof is
zinc there's nothing in the conservation
area down to Danton Road anything like
that it will be out of keeping thank you
so where you were looking in the respect
of your overlooking I will be on the
left-hand side of that that's that's my
house there yeah and be if you can see
between the [ __ ] of the trees there the
white portion from the ridge it goes out
53 feet into the rear garden we have a
balcony for exiting out our bedroom you
cannot serve as a technical question
obviously that's something that the
officer can yeah yes the other thing I
wanted to do is is this outbuilding at
the bottom of the garden because
essentially what the office is saying is
because it's it's 40 meters I think from
where the enter your property ends
essentially it's a sufficient distance
away to not really be bothersome even
though it is a big building what do you
say about that well I disagree with you
there unfortunately it is called
immediate sounds a lot but it isn't it
will be visibly intrusive and it is four
meters high with the three meter by 3
meter industrial door it will be seen I
can assure you I don't know if the
officers got I know that she took some
photographs it's no garden shed at the
end of the day I mean right any other
questions members no thank you very much
to music thank you thank you very much
you turn the microphone off of the
picture thank you right thank you
next a speaker is always Spicer and a
mic do host the applicant again you have
three minutes in your own time
yeah you can let's go there's about five
or six lines that's right
thank you good evening the application
before you this evening is a result on
previous application being refused and
dismissed at appeal although the appeal
decision was disappointing at the time
it's been very positive and Guardian
sought a new variety of devote proposals
before us evening the appeal inspector
was very clearly to report about key
issues that resulted in the dismissal
and we're not that the remaining areas
were deemed acceptable three reasons
were stated in the previous decision and
we've strived to redesign this
replacement dwelling so that these
reasons can be overturned and are fully
addressed the office this report states
clearly in the council's professional
opinion how this has been achieved
however just for the clarity of God to
address a couple of these points the
first reason stated for refusal was an
overbearing impact on the street scene
due to its size and mass and the
building's width been increased
constituting over development we
produced a proposed building to be
narrower than the existing building on
the site and is significantly lower than
the existing dwelling now it's been
repositioned if you just move I'm sorry
now it's been repositioned centrally on
the plot creating the large green gaps
between the neighboring properties far
larger than the currently available and
reviewed on today's select is it the
inspectors report noted the refused
application building width and large
flat roof nature filled the plot this
was the key showing the effect on the
street scene and we have been
redesigning the roof structure reduced
the height and scale through the varied
forms and create a building that is
visually that's impacting on the street
team on the next slide the slide
illustrates existing dwelling our
initial application the second one from
the top the third one down was the
application which was refused at appeal
and the bottom slide bottom image
indicates the proposed dwelling us today
with a red line being the existing
dwelling and the green areas being that
not which are now created which I've
never been there before do it the next
slide from we've a long one numerically
demonstrates this reduction in impact
and betterment of these proposals the
proposed dwelling will have a 22 square
meter benefit a numerical benefit over
the existing
let's learn the previous refused
application by way of a further example
produced impact the next slide has a
comparison photo montage demonstrating
the existing dwelling on the right hand
side of the image and a proposed
dwelling as montage on the left hand
side the very wood roof design load
bridge hi produces the scale provides a
lighter misleading Pierce that visually
produces bulk as noted by the inspector
in the appeal statement the two-story
and single-story aspects of the proposed
building on those who body inspector has
been acceptable in terms of impact on
amenity especially with number eighty a
although the single-story a swim port
which has now been thirty seconds please
impact area if you move on to the next
line the last relief slides are examples
of buildings that this committee has
over the last few years granted
permission to be constructed in around
Stratford in the conservation area they
really achieve and higher quality
architecture or demonstrations of this
product can we watch the next image dead
again they had the final image two final
slide now under construction is by local
firms I'm afraid you've run out of time
to join a quickly summarize please
quality architecture has a place by its
inclusion the historic corn the heritage
of our town is appreciated more by its
juxtaposition with modern contemporary
architecture of high quality thank you
very much indeed
let me there any questions you'd like
that Tesla's I think God I'm committee
when we reviewed which was obviously
these he's smaller have you spoken to
anybody like the Town Council inspector
we sat down with a kind of clean set
tracing papers or say with Council
evolve the very initial stages all of
the applications that have been put in
so far been wholly supported by the
offices and in brought to committee
through the consultation process with
Duvall the town council have never
objected to any of the applications that
have been put forward we've always
presented to them and have had no
representations on all occasions
we completely redress the scheme and
counselor wolf was supportive and
progressively this especially with this
latest set of information what the quad
garage at the front we were initially
we're gonna show you can I just pick up
a point um Alice to the side yeah that
currently farm long is that the one that
will be extending from the new building
into the garden is that the top one
there because it I think I'm wrong I
think this is the one that the neighbors
complain most about
yeah yes okay but do you feel though
that because it's such a flat roofed and
this is the criticism of the boy the
neighbor but that hasn't been addressed
as regards the frontage I see where
you're coming from on that particular
point but the sight do you think you've
addressed that issue
again thank you any other questions
quatre jours and council had various
sort of measurements in terms of
footprint I'm just trying to get CPR he
basically talked about a roughly two
hundred percent increase in total
footprint and then we've obviously heard
neighbor saying the ground floor is
about 91 percent bigger on the ground
floor are you able to give me some
percentages of what footprint is kind of
juggled around quite a lot over the last
couple years an interesting analysis if
you like if I say number 76 which is the
lower plot here it's for its dwelling
footprint compared to its plot size is
fifteen point one percent number eighty
a which is the house to the top and
interestingly was a house built in the
large garden if the large house has a
footprint even so of
10.5% so it's a small house and a
smaller part and the proposed dwelling
our dwelling it's fifteen percent its
footprint is very similar to both
immediate neighbors well I'm asking
there is what is the percentage increase
in footprint between what exists on that
plot and your proposal is just in terms
of footprint just under 50 percent you
can confirm that if you wish to with the
officer of the eat any more patient
capsule fielding you rush through the
compatible we you had to rush through
the comparable or modern buildings that
you were sharing in two slides are there
any other buildings of a similar style
along didn't enroll I know there's a lot
of variables there's one just go back
and again these are interesting so the
top left is a house on welcome Road it's
a very sweet tree-lined conservation
area
right
corner listed building as well as in
conservation area the bottom right if
you can see there is a house which is
built at the bottom of tintin mode we
designed and I saw the build a bit it is
set back slightly from the front and in
the field plot which is in the area and
it's interesting it's covered in black
zinc and it's got black bricks on the
base and the nests if you go to the next
slide there are the top left hand is a
modern parallelism I don't you can pick
up there at the top it's higher halo
roof is all pink so you've got a white
render building with expressed eaves
that very light thin which are clad in
zinc zinc is a modern material which is
has been raised it's a natural material
isn't man-made it comes out the ground
it's a very you know sustainable local
material both of the images on the right
the top right is in Houston
interestingly the last time this
application came to this committee more
interesting - I think you've answered
the question anyway Thank You counsel
Jones so I just want to do with the
garden building what it is large what's
the purpose of it
mike is a business which makes all sorts
of things bites for the Olympics carve
and farm bits and pieces
he collects cars all sorts of old cars
new cars so the reason we've designed
basement is to store cars his pride and
joy that he collects there that outside
away from the street so within the house
was a domestic paraphernalia won't be
within that zone so the garden store
it's a very large house it's been
designed to go in that area so all the
garden equipment the children's
equipments the three young children so I
can kind of hand you over but on that
basis yeah I think not wanting to keep
kids bikes and canoes and all the
paraphernalia that you acquire with
children when they want to do their
sporting activities and as they grow and
develop
you need the you can acquire a lot of a
lot of paraphernalia with the moment I
wanted to keep it out of the way at the
bottom the garden took it away really
our particular design point of view on
the site you'll see there the actual
section of land is a very strange shape
to the plot the way that Fox had been
divided is over the years it's kind of
like a Chinese finger shape so the
building is like the arbiter in fact it
sheiter of weight to fit in there so
because the land is thank you Casso jars
that answer your question
members or any other questions of our
speakers okay thank you very much right
our next speaker is caster frontally not
so short this time counselor may I say
that I was as cats love wolf cannot be
here she's away she actually asked me to
read her words this evening which I will
do okay here we are again this will be
the third time an application has been
brought forward for this plot you'll
have heard from the architect owner that
he has taken on board all comments made
by you as a committee at the previous
planning meetings and those comments
made by the inspector if you haven't
read the inspectors report I'd ask that
you take some time out to read it fully
it's quite damning and very precise in
its comments the architect I believe has
paid lip service to the inspectors
report he's removed the long building
facing a TA and it has made the house
slightly smaller however it is still
nearly three times bigger than the
original house and I must refer you to
policy CS 20 where it states that a
replacement dwelling should not be
visually intrusive and not significantly
larger than the dwelling it replaces
this proposed heart is eighteen and a
half thousand square feet with nearly
six and a half thousand square feet
underground which will house the garage
and the swimming pool
this leaves nearly 12,000 square feet
above ground this is a massive house out
of all proportion to the other houses
the road he has taken note of the
inspectors comments about the flat roof
but by doing this he has cosmetically
put in three pitched roofs at the front
covered with silver zinc these pitched
roofs will be covered in zinc which is a
shiny color not appropriate within a
conservation area and setting if you
look closely at the frontage you'll see
a huge master flat roof behind these
pictures although the picture is
slightly angled so that you don't see
all of the flat roofing this picture is
very misleading he has done this to make
it look more healthy and to overcome the
concerns of the inspector but all it is
doing is hiding the mass and bulk and
overbearing this of the two-story flat
roof building behind this will have a
huge impact on both neighbors as that is
all they will see at the back I'd like
to draw your attention to the proposed
garden stall in the garden this will be
a thousand square feet single storey
building and will be 4 meters high with
a 3 meter shutter door at the front the
size of this garden store is a similar
size to most three-bedroom houses which
are being built around the town this is
rather large for garden store and I
would suggest that it should require
separate planning application who has a
garden store that big this committee has
refused the two previous applications on
mass bulk over burying this an impact on
street scene has also refused both
previous applications of the failure to
preserve or enhance the character and
appearance of the conservation area this
has been backed up by the CP re
comments made by the CPR me on this
application make no real changed
previous comments all the comments this
committee has made on previous
applications have been upheld by the
inspector in his report it is essential
that you read the inspectors report in
full before we make any decision this
proposed house is still significantly
larger it is still overbearing a massive
bulk of the flat roofs it still does not
enhance the street scene it is still not
appropriate designing a console
the tootington road residents
association have met twice to determine
this application and have voted you -
unanimously to eject it on these grounds
I ask that you object this application
thank you little unfair asking you to
respond to questions on behalf of prom
you've been saying and I'm willing to
ask those technical questions in a
moment if I was okay with you okay thank
you very much indeed cancer right
technical questions first thing I would
like to actually I'd like to ask one is
the zinc obviously we have seen zinc
today it's evening in your opinion do
you think it will soften and sort of
soften down over time to sufficient does
not become true civ my view is that it's
obviously a more contemporary material
but for that reason I don't consider it
to be automatically inappropriate in the
conservation area as you said as we
picked up with it being used on the RSC
theater which is a grade-two stylistic
building within a conservation area
setting I did have a discussion with our
conservation officer on this point and
he considered the use of zinc to be
appropriate in this location although
it's a conservation area he considered
that the zinc would work well and appear
recessive to the lighter bricks used in
the elevations on the dwelling thank you
and the other one I just wanted to raise
before the members jump in is we've
always been looking at number 80 and the
distance of separation distances between
the the patio area there and the new the
area that projects from the bulk of the
house 76 have we done the same
calculations there and do you consider
that to be better or worse than it was
at the previous application please
the impact would be improved by virtue
of pulling it further away from this
side boundary in the assessment of the
last application members were satisfied
that previous concerns with the immunity
on this courtyard area have been
overcome with amendments reducing a
forward projecting garage which is over
here and similarly so it wasn't refused
on on the impact on number 76 and
similarly the inspector carries that
forward this is a swimming pool building
here so it has windows on all sides and
the separation distances between the two
buildings is considered to be acceptable
to retain an adequate level of immunity
for that dwelling and also the extension
the proposed piece that projects from
the building that's it yeah similarly
because you've got windows on all three
sides any impact would not be
significant thank you
Thank You chairman I've got two or five
I told you it's possible to show a wider
plan of the area showing I presume it's
ATB the reason I'm asking is the the the
plan we've got there we've got the three
garages they're all pretty much the same
but the applicant site here it seems to
be not following the line of the road it
seems to before they garage where a
three would sort of fit in but if you
looked at the houses next door does that
you happy that the positioning of it but
certainly that garage is in line with
the rest of the four houses it doesn't
look so when you look at 76 78 an 80 a
the difficulty with this map is it
doesn't actually show the full
projecting garage on number 76 if I just
go back to this plan here you see what I
mean yeah it seems to be one Bay too
many yeah III can see the point my view
is that it's still an adequate setback
from the public highway here and
obviously for projecting garages are
very characteristic of tilling to Road
the whole way along and my view is that
that the impact of that is acceptable
but obviously it's for members to to
weigh that up in the assessment
Asian okay fine and my second one if you
can keep on that and move your your
cursor down to the the two-story we keep
going down to have stopped what that is
it looks like a big lounge area or a
garden room it's either my eyes or so
first floor level in here we've got
master bedroom that was my second
question so that is a lounge garden room
and above it is is the master bedroom
it's a kitchen breakfast room at ground
floor level here and then a master
bedroom above it's a big house on a big
plot but how much smaller is it now
compare with what it was the distance
between the neighbor been reduced yeah
I've got a few of my own calculations in
terms of sort of footprint and so the
existing dwelling ground floor level so
ie the footprint equates to
approximately 340 square meters the
application which went to appeal and was
dismissed at appeal was approximately
880 square meters in floor area so
footprint at footprint knob total floor
area and this current amendment is
approximately 650 on footprints so
comparing the existing to proposed we've
got three hundred and forty square
meters is assisting six hundred and
fifty as proposed so it is still larger
than what's that we've heard various
percentages which is lovely things
people throw at us it's between 50 and
90 percent bigger do we have a
percentage just to clarify the percent
you're different later on so I can't do
but I mean you're going for three
hundred and forty to six hundred
so it's approximately doubling the size
in terms of footprints next question I
will ask then is because a significant
amount this is below ground does that is
that taken into account in your
calculations so that's the ground floor
area only in terms of we're looking at
total floor space so across the basement
ground and first law we're looking at
approximately 1,500 square meters for
the dwelling as proposed as existing
it's over the ground and first floor
level you're looking at approximately
520 square meters thank you any other
questions
I'm just double-check okay open to
debate
I just wonder because councillor Rolf
has invited us to read the inspectors
report and bearing in mind its recency
and how relevant it is I know that
there's potentially logistical issue
with it but I do wonder whether it is on
reflection important for members to read
it well just for reference
it's quoted within the report sent as an
email to I well I I apologize but I and
I know it's very very inconvenient but
would I be allowed five minutes to read
through that because I haven't seen it
which I appreciate I should have read
that before but I think it's important
that if anyone else hasn't nothing they
ought to as well
members I'm happy to suspend proceedings
for five minutes or ten minutes for
catalyst and any others to have a read
of the the inspectors report please
still so the voting will be suspended
for 40 minutes okay
an opportunity to read the inspectors
report as well okay thank you very much
everybody if you can just take your
seats thank you
right okay then as I started to say
we're open for debate looking at the
plan of the proposed plan it is a lot
smaller spread as far by the way as the
first one that when to dismiss appeal on
the other hand the two neighboring
properties are very close to the
boundary so anybody who tries to develop
something on this site and this is
really very small and then it would look
ridiculous on the site I'm going to come
off against this problem of the boundary
and the neighborhood the neighboring
properties and I think that in although
I don't like the some of the materials
used I think that it's it's a reason in
keeping with kidding tomorrow which is a
somewhat unusual road with so many
different designs and on it thank you
cancer bones and Cal security I did read
the report some days ago and I think the
important thing has been taken out the
bulk and size has been reduced she's a
big house on a big clock there are a lot
of different sorts of Hazard down that
road in the vicinity
I think they've addressed the inspectors
concern although the ward members is
still not happy but looking at the
reason for refusal that we put forward
before I think I think most of them have
been addressed cancer courage its
comment to start with I very much like
the old design and actually I very much
like this design as well but that's a
personal matter I think the new design
has addressed the issues that were men
and in the appeal decision and reduced
the width and removed the swimming pool
which was mentioned in the appeal
decision in fact I think they've
listened very carefully to what was said
in the report and and therefore I think
I would I would go along with the
officers recommendation on this and
recommend supporting it yes it's
obviously certainly an improvement on
the previous two proposals in the sense
that yes it's narrower and it addresses
leaving that gap between the properties
however that isn't the yardstick by
which we should be judging application
we need to judge it by what exists
currently and cs20 says that it
shouldn't be significantly larger I
think there can't be any denying that
this building is significantly larger
than that which is currently there and I
think the applicant zone you know it's
clear from the measurements we've got a
50% larger footprint however you could
say that on its own given the plot sizes
and what we're looking to do maybe it
would sort of scrape over the line
because yes it's significantly larger
but that's okay
breaches cs20 I think the concern for me
is that when you put that together with
the fact that the mid the the design and
the difference in design the question of
whether it enhances the this area and in
particular the fact that it's a
conservation area I think that's where
it becomes problematic because I think
you could have one of those things and
it may be be acceptable so you could
have a much smaller proposal with a
design that's maybe not in keeping with
the area and something a bit different
but it wouldn't be so noticeable but I
think when you put the breach of cs20
together with that design which I don't
think can be said possibly said to be in
keeping I know there's that one at the
bottom of tootington row that is quite
modern in design
it's set back it's very hidden in fact
it's you don't you have to search for it
it's not on the street front as search
and actually the even though there's a
degree of eclectic design on Teddington
Road it's not that eclectic it's it's
post-war it's there is an in keeping
style and I think this will look very
different now that's not to say we can't
do very different things in the district
but I think we have to be careful where
we're doing that in a row of houses
where that broadly there's a similar
style of materials and I think we have
to be very very careful where we're
allowing something which is
significantly larger will be very very
prominent and this is very very
different so I think and for me I am
concerned about the materials clearly
they're infinitely preferable to the
dark brick that was the previous
proposal because to me that was very
much not in keeping but I have to say
I'm not particularly convinced by the
argument that this light brick is going
to look like render I think it's going
to look noticeably different and that's
fine it's a noticeably different design
so for me I think when I just weigh up
the pros and the cons I think it's those
two concerns placing them together I
think you're in real danger of having
something which looks it's too much
Maasai's and the design altogether it's
just it's it's not right we should feel
comfortable we should feel comfortable
with what we're approving it should
enhance we shouldn't have reservations
you know there's a lot of scope to put
something on this problem we shouldn't
be feeling this is a good idea and I
don't feel I can go yeah waterside yeah
you know great it works and there's
modern bits and there's other modern
things we've put in the district but I
don't feel that I can just say thank you
major problem the design especially the
frontage I'm not convinced does it
enhance the street scene and I think
that was when the arguments that was
poured by the inspector I don't think it
significantly detract from it either so
in that respect
I'm not too concerned about the street
scene side of things I do feel that the
modernist design in its context
certainly from the front looks fine in
that respect I'm happy with that but the
side is very blocky again and flat roof
and I feel that that isn't as nice as it
could be we do have some plot plugs
showing the sizes and it is interesting
of course we are lacking I'm actually
now making a comparison between the
original design which was refused and
this one which isn't the smaller and the
plot but it's still significantly large
bulky building and the game this is the
this is the question that we we have to
decide on is it still overbearing is it
still through its mass and both can
scale too big for this particular plot
so I'm I'm not yet on this on the one
hand I agree first but if you wish to
just respond to them because you saying
that it occurs to me that I think I
think it is a fair criticism to say is
this gay bling ever so slightly cosmetic
because actually it's interesting having
that drawing up the flatness which i
think is a very genuine criticism of
this design that flatness really it's
covered up by a bit of cosmetic there
and the question then is what is the
impression to the neighbors of that and
actually I think there is a I think
there is a legitimate argument say for
the neighbors impression and that the
visual intrusiveness for them because
it's not just to do with the size it's
about what it looks like that's visual
actually is it going to look very flat
and blocky from there from their
perspective and I unlike I think
probably is going to thank you Jer well
again design is designed and it is a
very personal thing I I personally think
this is a much much better elevation
that there was previously proposed which
is almost industrial in its look but
that's that's my view that I don't think
that's an issue that is going to weigh
heavily in my decision on this
what I am concerned and I think it's
been raised by council of Josas this is
a very big building and whether it does
breach or cs20 in that I would counter
that by saying what a lot of it is
underground and we have had recent
decisions by inspectors we're
underground basements effectively not
counted so that little thing I have two
things that worry me
one is the garage at the bottom which at
four meters high is pretty much an
industrial unit not a garage and I would
have thought that a building of three
meters high would be more than
sufficient to house lawnmowers and
bicycles and and what-have-you but we
have what we have at the moment and the
second thing is I really think that the
protrusion to the to the south of the
site which is this large kitchen diner
if that was a single storey I'd be a lot
happier but it's having the extra master
bedroom on the top that worries me
because I think that does affect the
amenity of a TA I would love to see the
master bedroom within the bulk of the
building it would reduce the size of the
building that's where I am now to be
fair I'm not quite sure whether those
reasons are actually adequate planning
reasons to turn this down
these are personal views I don't have to
think about it yet thank you I think I
think the the concern that's coming over
to me certainly from this side is on the
size of the public and the scale of the
property and whether that is an
appropriate to say on materials it's a
tricky one because we've seen today zinc
which is quite bright when it's new does
fade in time and we've seen that today
from
so I don't have a problem with that but
size of the materials and I think they
have materials choices are better than
it was so again I'm still saying that in
some many respects are quite like the
design I just think the sizable scale is
a bit of an issue to me
Caliban counsellor characters proposed
it okay we have any other people for
debate no okay then members the the vote
before you is to grant planning
permission for 17 / 0 1 4 7 12 / 4 all
those in favor those against this
committee therefore resolves to grant
planning permission for 1701 4 7 4/4
thank you very much indeed
thank you very much
our next item on the agenda thank you
very much everybody
our next item on the agenda is 1700 to
double 67 special very which is riksha
Grange
Thank You chair the application before
is this evening is for relating to the
holiday caravan site on Southside wicks
furred members may recall in June and
the application was refused to remove
the occupancy restriction to allow the
caravans to be occupied for a full year
that was refused the application now is
to retain an occupancy restriction but
to limit that to one month so reducing
it by one month so that's just a little
bit of background so here we have the
the village and the black spot showing
the position of the caravan site and
then we have the caravan site location
three horseshoes pub on the southeast
side in the village how you brook
running on here along the southern
boundary which feeds into the river
arrow on the west side just off the the
main constraint on the site is the fact
that the virtually the whole of the site
is Inns up there flood zone three B
which is the functional floodplain and
advice from the Environment Agency is
that the caravans were allowed on the
basis of a very very well considered
compromise if members will
cuz their minds back to when this was
originally allowed
I'm just taking on a bit of a history
tour here the there was a certificate
certificate of lawfulness for the site
allowed for 56 caravans originally so it
was a historic site we then have an
application to reduce the number of
caravans but also to have five dwellings
affected as part of the sort of deal if
you like and careful consideration was
given to the fact that the caravan site
is in a floodplain and the the
Environment Agency concei riously
considered the package of flood
mitigation measures that would allow
them to hesitantly I should say move
forward with with allowing the caravan
site and the position now of the
Environment Agency is that having concea
Slee considered that package of
mitigation which included a restriction
of two months they feel that they're
unable to move on on that compromise
position having seriously considered it
before and feel that the additional
month would introduce additional risk
for occupants and on balance felt that
that wasn't something that they could
support so the recommendation is to
refuse I don't really have a lot more to
say chair I think that really sums it up
oh yes just a little procedural points
if members decide to overturn the
recommendation is evening I just bring
two members attention that the
application would have to be referred to
the Secretary of State to give him the
opportunity to decide whether or not to
to call in the application so that's
just a procedural note
yeah thank you our first speaker this
evening is Dean Morris co-chairman all
hooks with parish council you have three
minutes in your own time
here we go
don't touch it okay thank you I'm
learning they the position of the parish
council is that we support we support
application we supported the last
application which would have been even
better for us than this one but we
support this one as well because this is
ultimately better for the village in our
view than the the default position which
is the existing 32 units over sorry yes
so the the the default position is 32
caravans 4 for 10 months and obviously
for a village we would prefer there were
less caravans and more caravans for
obvious reasons in terms of the the the
traffic and disturbance and obviously
there are people bordering the the park
and if we have a greater number of units
used for holiday purposes then the
disturbance to thee to the surrounding
properties is greater so per say having
less units is better for us and that's
one of the reasons we support it from 32
to 29 in terms of the extra month we
would we think that the spin-off effect
for us in that regard will be that we'll
end up with less holidaymakers and more
owner-occupiers
and before the village to have not
permanent residents but residents who
are only occupies that are more
permanently resident than transient
holidaymakers that come and go so having
that that the extra period is likely to
encourage that type of owner which is an
owner that we would prefer to have in
the village than transient holidaymakers
that come and go and may make a lot of
noise when they're here etc so
for those two principal reasons we
support it over the default position
which is the thirty-two over ten months
we're a little confused really in terms
of the Environment Agency's objection
that haven't really it's a sort of stick
their finger in the air approach there's
a trade-off between reducing the number
of caravans and reducing the risk by
virtue of the lesser numbers but
increasing the risk because you're
adding a month occupancy there seems to
be rather an art with tria 30 seconds
please
rather an arbitrary approach to what's
acceptable and what isn't and in terms
of the trade-off
what are they say is acceptable if 29
units is not an acceptable reduction to
them then what is so I don't think I can
say great till more thank you thank you
I've just got one question obviously at
the previous application which was
refused one of the major factors if I
remember correctly and I may be
corrected is the fact that it's in flood
zone 3b how do you I think I mean I
don't I don't know that the full
technicalities because I'm not a flood
expert but as I understand it part of
the site it is is within that zone I
think there are great as I understand it
but but our position is as a village I
mean we've I've lived there for a long
time so I know how that manifests itself
on the ground and the very worst it's
manifested itself on the ground in my
experience is about I've engaged inches
of water at one end of the caravan park
was my last experiences C's on the
ground and obviously all these caravans
have got flotation devices and
everything else so I accept that that
the flood zone that it's in is the flood
zone of the team it's Demark to search
practically I'm saying that that there
are no significant manifestations of
that certainly to the
occupancy of these caravans and and I
just wanted to know your particular
views were on the risk to the residents
that was it my views are that the risk
to thirty-two caravans over ten months
is not materially different to the risk
over twenty nine over eleven that's
Michael as you thank you are there any
other questions members no thank you
very much and thank you just press the
microphone as you leave thank you
alright our next speaker is Nick Allen
and Andy Murphy for today so you just
got me for the for the three minutes
thank you very much for giving us a time
speak um I was here a few months ago
when we went forward 12 months have now
put that back down to 11 months so it's
gonna be a holiday site my family is
very short and sweet again the biggest
floods that we've seen in Stratford
April 98 July 1961 November 2012 in July
2007 Karen park would be open all of
those times we're looking for an x2 one
month and it I find it a bit bizarre
because there's something that the
council have already done for other
caravan parks in the area and so at the
counts have already done for other
parking area that are in flood zones too
and it's actually this committee as he
supported an application that was in the
flood zone of another caravan park so
even side and Welford went from 10
months to 11 months that's in flood zone
with the VB and also the Willows avid
sulphate as I understand it was this
committee that were asked to support it
to 12 months and they refused they
didn't refuse 12 months they asked to be
renegotiated and in the end the Willows
got 11 months licensed both those parks
are in the flood zone exactly the same
as Wickford our pod where's the the hey
book at the end of the day we are not I
see on a river like Aven side all the
Willows we're at sea on a book the
deserted backup
and our problem is about 8 to 10 inches
we think we were a good tight ship we've
got parks and stuff upon a van we are
quite used to the floods and we've done
our utmost to put all the procedures in
we can to make sure that the holiday
homeowners and that cabins are safe and
we do run a tight ship a day and peopled
off if and when we have to hopefully
you'll be able to support this
application as you've been tolerated by
accountable this won't be the last I'll
have to go to the sexist State for it to
be looked at again I do hope you can
support it application for 11 months
thank you how about any questions you'd
like to ask just one obviously you
mentioned about the hey Brooke when you
were here before there was talk about
the Brooking itself and the fact that I
believe again memory that to mitigate
the flooding issues that Brooke would
need to be cleared and made to flow more
freely how's anything happened on that
we do clear it out and we have cleared
out a lot more than it was okay I'm not
sure that answer the question but yes
okay it has maintained and I think in
the last the in the last few months we
have I see other diggers into to
maintain and take stuff out of it okay
thank you any other questions members
cosmos we just don't do as they might
reduce the number we reduced the number
increases I'm trying to give the
Environment Agency a again at the end of
the day there's gonna be less days where
where people are affected by the flood
because of it so that's why we don't
need the less numbers and the extra
month okay thank you very much
counter Adams are speaking on this one
thank you
good evening to Chairman I support the
parish council with their comments the
reduction in the number of caravans can
only be of benefit the overall site and
village and that by increasing the
occupancy to 11 months will probably
encourage more permanent residents and
hopefully they will get involved in
village life and rather than just being
holiday occupancy I realized that the
environmental environmental agency have
concerns but I think the last big flood
was in July 2007 and of course that
wasn't in the winter months thank you
Thank You council any questions that I
can sir no thank you very much right
technical questions obviously the first
one is the flooding element of this and
the EA's response could you just quickly
go over that again please anything yes
certainly thank you chair the BAA
wrote their response and as I saying to
you before they have considered the
reduction by three units but but
consider that just reading here they
said virtually the whole sighted and
functional floodplain zone 3 B and our
position is that the site being at risk
for an extra months of the year compared
to the capacity of the site it fully if
follow being slightly reduced does not
cancel each other out so despite the
offer I think the Environment Agency's
conclusion is that the extra month
introduces extra risk and that isn't
that isn't sort of mitigated any further
compared to what what was proposed
before and therefore that position is to
draw that line in the sand and say that
was our compromised position and that's
as far as we all go any other technical
questions
okay open to debate Castro's Environment
Agency have given this counsel
professional advice about what they
think is appropriate risk mitigation and
they're very clear that they consider
the ten months is necessary risk
mitigation to allow occupation on this
site to exist given it's in a floodplain
and that makes sense in many ways to me
so I would be supporting the
recommendation to refuse the variation
of condition council bonds I have a
number of these sites right by the river
this is I dunno this site or was the
county councillor when it did flood it
floods again the field stops at the road
and then it's back flow here
one minute they're saying no next minute
they're saying yes some even right by
the river they've given it loud for for
12 months of the year as long as they're
on stands so far as I'm concerned
they're in the site normally it doesn't
floored when the people aren't there
long as you may the point is that you
usually usually it's in sort of August
or September when we get floods not in
the winter when we get a lot of water
because the water can then be controlled
so as far as I'm concerned I am this I
would be happy to go along with the
parish council that's my personal view
because as I say all the way along the
river and this isn't along the river
they make different decisions at
different places and now I can't
understand where they're coming from I
just respond to that particular point
and is interesting that actually quite a
number of floods have occurred in July
it's one of the big big flood periods in
this country but I'll just that's where
all the holiday makers are that's we
need a good warning system
that's the important thing t normally
they don't allow them just after
Christmas well that's the farm when the
water is we don't get the right thank
you the question thing is that oh I'd
like to support this I really would like
to support it I feel that this is a it's
a good site in fact having listened to
the PC about this the the argument they
put forward for permanent residency on
theirs is quite strong and like I get
that all of it as well I don't feel that
I'm happy enough yet to say that the the
brook for example has been so we say
clear sufficiently or modified to some
form to actually reduce the flooding
risk there and I should say I used to go
to school past this is I trust the 300
shoes and I've actually seen it floated
up to a meter there so I do know it can
follow it in that particular area now
I'm not saying that things haven't
happened over the over the period I
would like to support this but in this
moment I can't go against the EA and I
do that because I've seen the effects of
flooding I live next to a river and so I
can't support but I will support the
officers recommendation on this one
I just want to deal with counts the
Barnes's point about I can't understand
why different decisions are made in
different parts of the district well
that's because he's not a qualified
member of the Environment Agency of
course is going to be different
considerations for different sites they
have different they have different
levels of the land all sorts of
different considerations apply and
that's why we ask for an expert risk
assessment for an expert body about what
is it appropriate flood mitigation risk
it's really quite simple
I don't just find quite fast
I don't be personally I do find that
quite a facile comment because don't
think it's appropriate to sort of bring
anecdotal evidence in in that way
because I think we the brook there if
it's clear down to the arrow there isn't
a problem most of the problem on that
particular site is trees it is only a
brook that's why floats because
backflow counselor carriage I do
apologize I missed you well there you
are having such fun I just like the
second modest proposal to go with this
Katalin Thank You chair yeah I mean I'm
very sympathetic with the parish council
and and the ward member here I
completely get the point that a
reduction in the amount of caravans and
again I would be very happy to support
12 months of the year to actually have
permanence I think the thing that's
weighing me here is is is the line here
in this application there is no further
work or mitigation measures are proposed
as part of this application and I would
have thought if the applicant came back
with proposals to mitigate the flooding
whether that is putting permanent units
on stilts even if it might be a meter
above week we all know if caravan parks
certainly there in my ward where it's
closer to the river they are raised up I
mean if that came back I think it would
be happy but I'm not going to go against
the officers recommendation because of
that reason and counsel John did you
propose I didn't but I'm happy to
propose okay and councilor carried you
are oh you're willing to second on that
there are members the vote before is to
refuse planning permission for 17/2
double six seven slash very all those in
favor against abstain thank you this
committee there for a result of to
refuse planning permission for 17-0 two
six six seven seven Sasha very thank you
the next item on the agenda is 17/2
double 5/8 Ashbury and that is the ridge
Langley Road Abbadon the presenting
officer is Amy
[Applause]
Thank You German the application site
notify the black dot is within the
southern part of kravid n' a local
service village within the West Midlands
Greenbelt the site aged red is situated
south of Langley Road with residential
dwellings to the east and west and open
countryside to the south and a public
right-of-way planning permission was
approved in August 2017 for a
replacement dwelling with integral area
garage and associated works permission
is sought to vary the access
arrangements for the site from a
singular access point of Langley Road to
include a second access point to create
an in/out access arrangement the second
access would be sited northeast of the
existing access point so this is the
existing and this is the additional
access point which is proposed the
aerial photo shows the relationship of
the application sites in relation to
neighboring properties there are
examples have been out driveways within
the immediate street scene to the west
just here so the top left image shows
the site's existing access and is
looking in a northeasterly direction
towards the siting of the proposed new
access which will be positioned
approximately in the location of the top
right image which looks in a
southwesterly direction the bottom image
is an internal photo of the site no
additional trees would be lost
other than those detailed within the
original application I will now show you
a short video of this part of Langley
Road
bear with me a moment okay if I just
pause it here a moment you'll see a
white car in the distance and this
access which is viewable now these are
both the access points which serve the
adjoining dwelling and to the
application site known as the feed
Fielding's moving in a northeasterly
direction towards the application site
just wait while the video catches up you
will see the current access for the
application site and then as the video
moves on you will see where the proposed
new access will go I'll just go back at
the net so you can here we go so the new
access will be positioned around about
the point where my cursor is now
they're with me so this slide shows
existing boundary treatments and used at
properties adjacent to the site and as
you can see a mix of soft and hard
treatments are used chairman the
recommendation is to grant the
application subject to the reasons as
detailed in the committee report and
just to make you aware there is a little
update which I did mention and that just
clarifies that no additional trees will
be lost as a result of the new access
thank you Amy our first speaker is
councillor Walton thank you chairman if
you've already done it thank you very
much
the reason that cloud and parish council
of the force this to committee it is
very simple on the drawing to the to the
left up there we were quite happy with
that there are a number of houses the
fielding is whatever that have been
developed there's no problem with it but
we did think that because the existing
house only had a single access whereas
the Fielding's that the the the offices
member did have double dual access
whenever we insisted that they changed
the plans and they did and they came
back with the plan on the left and we
were all happy with it we didn't object
and then well this was in August so
we're now in September October along
came another plan showing that you'll
access parish council feels that this is
incredibly unneighborly because they had
actually agreed a single access with the
neighbors and not more and more further
afield some of the occupants certainly
on the corner of Langley Road and Church
Road here they feel it as an intrusion
that is a very various long-established
hedge and I do take the point that there
are several multimillion-pound houses
there with dual accesses but when you
look at the one on the left there's
plenty of room to turn a car round you
don't need to swing in and sweep out and
this is the only reason we've got
there's no need for a second access
it's a shame to disturb a long line of
assisting hedge and the residential
amenity is is going to be affected
whether you consider that to be a
planning reason I don't know thank you
Jeff
thank you can I just answer tain what
the planning reasons were for refusal by
of the first time around for the first
time round we we made a request we made
a request because the neighbors asked us
to and the applicant at the time change
their plans there was no argument about
it as far as I can recall and ii realize
when they came to talk to the parish
council said we're gonna do this we said
fine the only thing we want to maintain
is the hedge any we don't want the trees
removed and we'll keep a single access
they said yes we didn't object to the
first application we're rejecting the
second because they're just come along
change their minds thinking it'll be an
easy deal and without scant regard to
the wishes of the neighbors okay I think
in planning terms that week we were
struggling we are coming up with okay
interesting
I shall arson streets and Street Saints
obviously thing of the office we're in
the moment on technical questions thank
you right thank you for that
any other questions of council Walton no
okay
I shot and out have some technical
questions any questions I first what I'd
like to ask is I noticed on the your
video which is very good there's a sign
post I assume is a 13-mile a sign post
is there an issue with that and
co-related with that are there any
issues with visibilities glaze on here
but this a second exit entrance
and referring to and the potential
visibility issues highways have asserted
the application and they've raised no
objections and they've only requested
that if members are minded to approve
permission that there is a condition to
control the direction that the gates
swing onto the highway and with regards
to the 30-mile our sign I don't I can't
foresee that it would create an issue
and highways haven't raised it within
their comments so presumably it's
something maybe where the sign could if
it was going to be an issue just maybe
be relocated just a quick one on this
permitted development rights on this
property are they still there and could
they do this on the permitted
development just out of interest and so
the chief at the 2017 permission which
was approved earlier this year the
applicants haven't implemented that
permission yet so with regards to
permitted development right the current
property has its permitted development
rights intact I had a conversation with
highways officer earlier this week who
confirmed that Langley Road is a de Road
which is unclassified and so and
permitted development and the access
could be constructed in the current form
of the current dwelling and prior to the
seven prior to no implementation of the
17 permission that already exists okay
thank you can security that's the key
really isn't it um serious thing they
could just do it now I thought we've
finished all that I thought that now you
you couldn't sort of do something on an
old property which contributed to the
new property because you end up with a
property different to the one with
permission you've got
so they put if they put a new access in
now before they start building what they
end up is is something on the right
which they haven't got planning
Commission for would that would that be
acceptable
I think the clarification purposes yes
they could they could use the existing
permitted development rights to
construct and access an Indian art
access arrangement ended in our
assessment obviously when it came to
implementing the planning permission
what they don't have then is plans and a
layout which then accords with the with
the consented drawings I think the
position that the case offers to taken
is we have felt it appropriate to assess
a fullback effectively the fallback
position which would be as it currently
stands they could provide an in-out
in-out access now and to finally clarify
that hopefully they could provide any
nice access now but if they wanted to
build out they'd have to block it up
again they wouldn't be in compliant way
they wouldn't be in accordance with the
approved plans because he approved plans
show a single single access point okay
I'll do me thanks okay any other
questions debate well if council Orton
chronology is correct it would indicate
there is a rather cynical aspect to this
application in so far as you ask for the
support in exchange for compromise and
then dispense with that compromise it's
a later date so it is I think unable is
quite a good word for that if that is
the case and we haven't been able to
question the applicant as to the
necessity of this however I think it's
also fair to say that any destruction of
hedge creating a bigger gap which makes
you look at a you know see more of the
property in what is a very rural area
rural type of Road causes some harm I
think the question is whether it's an
acceptable level of harm and I think
bearing in mind there are double
accesses along that road
it's difficult to say that that crosses
the threshold to say that it's an
unacceptable level of harm so with some
reluctance I have to say I would be
minded to support the officers
recommendation I think count secures in
council fielding I think you're unable
Yunus argument is fine and although it's
not specifically mentioned in in the NPP
f it does that there's kind of a clause
on consultation with with the neighbors
in the community which this absolutely
flies in the face of so I think you
could use the NPP FS comments on
consultation and stuff like that as an
argument the original plan was was
approved by by the parish specifically
because of this consultation we're not
just looking at and I Drive a new driver
we're looking at you know a completely
new application in in that case it's not
just an application for a driveway so we
I haven't heard the word on labor the
application for the original house but I
can't remember it so so I'm not looking
at that I think it's fair to assume that
this this new addition could be the
straw that broke the camel's back in not
accepting the original application so I
don't see why we should accept it now
and I would use what is it are you going
to tell me landscape what numbers that
cs5 landscape exactly I mean there's
lots in their proposals have regard to
the local distinctiveness of the
districts measures are incorporated into
the development scheme to enhance and
restore the landscape character for
locality this is exactly the opposite of
that it's taking away a hedge which is
part of the character of the locality
new landscaping proposals are
incorporated to reduce predicted harmful
visual impacts again this is exactly the
opposite of that so this is the opposite
of what our policies recommend small
harm now it may be it is hard there's no
need for it so I would go against
officers in this case and recommend
refusal counseling first in captures we
had a precedent in one of the villages
where I was parish chairman where a
house wanted to put a driveway in as
with other houses on the went to
highways to try and prevent it happening
we went to the planning on their grounds
that he was on classified Road we were
unable to stop the driveway being
created so it I think it's a difficult
one because this is an unclassified Road
you're going across highways land I
would sink and okay you're gonna I can
knock a hole in the hedge which is what
these people did in the village so there
is precedent of this sort of thing
happening with our Planning Commission I
should have probably Caesars technical
questions but it has just occurred to me
and obviously this is Greenbelt is it so
because because sometimes we see in our
recommendations that where the hard
standing is increased within the site
that that is felt to be an unacceptable
impact on the Greenbow why was that not
considered to be the case here
okay within my office's report and I'll
just read you a paragraph so the
driveway acts as an additional higher
standing area is considered an
engineering operate operation which is
not considered inappropriate development
within the green belt and if I provided
the openness is preserved so within the
NP PF and engineering operations are
considered appropriate so that's that's
asset falls under one of the exceptions
right correct I'm just going to get
Karen to clarify PD rights because I did
raise that and I didn't think we can
completely might get my head round it
completely rather than referring you to
the existing position referring back to
the planet the original planning
permission for this development
obviously this is a variation so we
would be replicating the appropriate
conditions in the new in the variation
permission permitted development rights
were restricted on classes a to e now to
the previous position those didn't
include a restriction on new on accesses
into the site so potentially
theoretically once the house is
constructed and occupied permitted
development rights would then the court
would then apply to this to for the
owners my view is in fact at that point
they could actually utilize their
permitted development rights to put in a
driveway I didn't have lost once we come
back on that we didn't take away the PD
rights for putting in access and access
point yeah if the relevant permitted
development right wasn't taken away from
the existing permission then then then
the driveway could be constructed
pursuant to permitted
right anyway I think he's what Karen
saying so are we saying they can put it
in anyway so I wasn't happy with it but
if they can put it in anyway I can't do
much better can I [ __ ] just clarify
the permitted development rights only
only apply once the property is
completed and occupied okay I think I
think way I'm reading this one it's
quite quite interesting isn't it for
what is on the surface of a relatively
small thing my view is that there's a
certain amount of nose out knows how to
joint on this particular one by the
parish and I get that after all they
talk to the applicants and they thought
they had an agreement and then they came
back with another one but we have seen
that in the past and we've seen it many
many times in the past on the other hand
I am struggling to see a reason to
refuse it and I think we're trying to
make up as various reasons to be honest
with you there is no real reason to
refuse this and that's from a planning
position but perspective now the thing
also is if the PD rights are there and
one form another and it's still
complicated as far as I'm concerned then
I think that's just going to happen
anyway so reluctantly I am going to
support the officers recommendations on
this one although I'm happy to propose
that councillor fielding comment and I
have a proposal I have a seconder
members the vote before you is to grant
at Planning Commission for 17 - OH
- 5 5 8 / very all those in favor
against abstain one abstention
thank you this committee therefore
resolves to grant applying for Bishop
75202 5 5 8 / Barry thank you
the next item on the agenda is the
Ulster members club and I will be
standing down as will councillor pain
thank you right counselors this is the
next item is item 17 oblique 0 1 1 3 3
oblique full it is the older members
club axe and face Road in Ulster we have
a presentation I think from le wrench
Eddie laughs team thank you Jeff
the site is located in the bill to bury
a boundary of Ulster just to the
northeast of the town center across the
river arrow as denoted here by the black
dot in the center so it's currently a
working men's club set to the southern
edge of the Conway residential estate
which is to the north this is an aerial
photo of the site is showing the
surrounding built form and uses this is
the existing floor plan which shows
concert hall area here lounge to this
area and then the club part to this area
the proposal is to retain the pub area a
bar area sorry in this area here and
then convert the lounge and concert hall
areas to a bed-and-breakfast as part of
that there would be a mezzanine floor
inserted for additional bedroom space in
the current concert hall area this slide
shows the existing and proposed
elevations mainly with fenestration
changes so smaller window types replaced
some renewing of render and also
emergency stairwell also inserted for
the proposed mezzanine level this is the
proposed site plan the proposal includes
an extension of the of the car parking
area of this area to the rear of the
bill
also as part of the plans
there's boundary treatment improvements
to the boundaries specifically to the
ones adjacent to the road so there would
be trees inserted and landscaping around
the periphery of the site and this is a
current view of the site from the corner
Junction it's at the moment it's all car
park to the front quite a stark hard
surface to the front as currently part
of a proposal works have started
although they aren't working at the
moment but as you can see here some of
the windows have been inserted chairman
the recommendation is to grant
permission such as to the five
conditions outlined on page 30 and the
update thank you Thank You Eddie are we
have nobody here from the parish council
Oh certainly not my sheet so our first
second speaker first speaker is Mrs S
Adams as a resident as opposed to a
counselor okay
Thank You mr. chairman I'm speaking as a
resident of the Conway estate where the
premises for this application are
situated I am injecting as a major part
of this work has been completed and so
the application is part retrospective
and I feel that residents didn't have
the opportunity and were not consulted
prior to the work commencing residents
that had booked the Community Hall were
told
back in March that the club were not
going to honor bookings made for July
this year so this change must have been
planned way back I haven't seen any
proven need for this type of
accommodation in the term three years
ago a small hotel closed because of lack
of use and was converted into flats and
this year a bed-and-breakfast property
in the town center ceased trading and
that also has been converted into two
dwellings the present we have a Travel
Lodge with 60 sea
letting rooms the king's court hotel
with 61 rooms and the Swan Hotel with 8
rooms
I feel Austria that are currently
covered with bed-and-breakfast
accommodation and we do not need to
promote visitors accommodation for
tourists the report does say on the
principle of development alias two of
the core strategy that the developers
are expected to contribute to the
achievement of these principles when it
is appropriate and b2 as quoted
improving the recreation and leisure
facilities in the town when in fact we
are losing a large community room
Austria's lacking in community
facilities since the closure of the
grade centre originally seven trains
will 7 trains comments were that details
of the drainage plans should be
submitted prior to work commencing too
late the work has started and gone a
long way I have concerns over the
parking site allocated with 31 rooms
plus the manager's accommodation it
leaves few spaces with patrons also if
this application is successful I would
like to see a sympathetic lighting
scheme so it doesn't impact on
neighboring properties especially
oversea house which our retirement flats
into Grade II listed building I also
have concerns over noise but I see from
the report that the submitted planning
statement said that it see it's the
intention of the owners to have an
earlier closing time for the bar and
this of course will come up 30 seconds
multiplies to vary the alcohol license
which they have to do due to the
alteration of the premises thank you
Thank You councillor very timely Council
I appreciate concerns about the
potential retrospective nature of or
part retrospective nature of it but do
you not see some benefit here in terms
of rejuvenating this because obviously
there is some evidence that this
potentially struggles of to become as a
viable business
and actually if this is turned into
accommodation and it might be
accommodation that's for example more
affordable to construction workers
whatever you then bring back into life
that is a bar and a pub and and increase
its viability and presence I agree that
perhaps you know the building just
needed rejuvenating 231 1-bedroom
accommodation saying the report that the
town council funded at the moment is not
viable but it could be with this
application it says says if the Town
Council said that the president time the
working men's club or whatever you like
to call members look he's not viable
this is there from what I can gather
from the application a way of keeping
the club still there but not using all
of it I mean we've heard that it's going
to be for tourists as far as Eddie's
concerned I've heard it's going to be
for builders you know I just can't see
successful thank you if I may again I'm
noticing that also the town councilor
who did object went and saw we only
working men's club and we're obviously
unimpressed or impressed I don't know
what it is the same well there is very
similar sort of operations and they
actually really took their objection
away because of that have you got any
comment on that
yes the town counts some of the town
councillors the Planning Committee went
on a site visit to really castle which
is in Birmingham and wheeler castle is a
different animal to a market town in
Warwickshire Thank You councillor
fielding in the site visits that we did
this afternoon a hotel that needed to
expand to create more bedroom space and
the indications I got is that there is a
demand for hotels and hotel space within
the district
I appreciate the type of occupant may
not be of the exclusive nature but on
the other hand it is a workingman's club
and it provides probably very good
bed-and-breakfast for working community
who are transient at the best of times
is surely that is something that you
should offer in the area was that was
that a question not a question well I
think that was a comment not a question
councillors any any other questions you
talked about lighting have you got any
specific lighting issues that you would
want to be address is it that you would
just want this lighting scheme to be
sensitive given the proximity of the
listed building and residential or have
you got any specific requests in
relation to the lighting thank you our
next speakers were two speakers actually
are the applicants and supporters andy
wilkins
and karen Stephens you have three
minutes
good evening and thank you chair and
members for the opportunity of
addressing you tonight
Caryn's with me should you have any
queries were with regards to the
operation of the club this application
provides some much-needed investment to
a members Club
located in the Conway and Tanika housing
estate which is the most deprived Ward
in the district it proposes the loss of
a function million being replaced by 31
Bed and Breakfast rooms over the past
three decades over 50% of clubs such of
this as this have been closed this
change will ensure that members club
this members clubs longevity for what
are very different times of those where
members clubs like this for economic and
viable it is against this backdrop that
operations like this need to adapt and
to change or to face the consequences a
hundred and nineteen members have signed
a petition supporting this application
as they believe and support the
diversification of the club and the
benefits that this will bring to this
important community facility admittedly
this application didn't start off on the
best foot in there had been a lack of
local consultation and the owner a
publican commenced some initial
preparatory works before a plan did
planning decision had been made
he then consulted me about these issues
work stopped immediately and we sought
to consult proactively with the Town
Council we attended a town council
meeting together and Paul apologized for
commencing works what's also explaining
the reasoning behind the application and
investment that he wanted to make Town
Council members accepted his offer of a
visit to a comparable operation that he
runs at Whaley workingmen's Club here it
was evident to see the difficulties that
clubs like this face today and how they
can be similarly adapted yet still
provide an important community facility
in addition to this a request was made
about improvements to the external
landscaping these were then incorporated
and subsequently the Town Council remove
their objection thirty-one affordable
overnight rooms have been proposed run
by professional outfit for the loss of a
function room that never really
successfully functioned there are not
many locations where Stratford can offer
a reasonably priced accommodation beer
for tourists or for people
working in around the district can
compromise details with regards to the
anticipated occupiers this application
is about ensuring that this community
facility remains at a sustainable
enterprise employing people and
maintaining an important contribution to
the area members as your officer
identifies in his report this proposal
fits all square with your core strategy
and we support your officers
recommendation thank you thank you I
presume that Karen you would be prepared
to answer any questions any questions
councillor fielding we've successfully
turned working looked round they
historically there were very very viable
businesses and times have changed where
the communities don't use them like they
did so if this was successful this would
be our fourth working man club that
we've turned into bed-and-breakfast the
one I'd make more can para para
somewhere that is the phase League which
is a market town just on the outskirts
of Staffordshire where we've done 24
bedrooms there that club was struggling
very badly was doing about 4,000 pound a
week where we've managed to take it up
to make it viable as a business and the
majority of people that use the bedrooms
are three bookings calm you're quite
right a lot of them are white and men
and lots of families that are travelling
because they're affordable it means that
there's a hot food offer which is an
amenity not only to the people that are
staying but an amenity to the community
it increases the footfall of people that
we employ in them but obviously the
football that goes through
and I took a number of members from our
Festa over to wheely castle so that they
could see that and I also took them to
the phase lay which for me is more of a
comparison and they got to talk to the
people in there and I think really that
was what changed people's perspective of
what we wanted to do okay think I think
I think you answered the question and
made the elite the economic case thank
you
councillor Barnes you said there was a
petition supported you the members all
well the majority of our bookings come
through booking.com and there are lots I
can only talk on history in my other
units a lot of the people are workmen
tourists families coming to the area so
they will be able to drink in the club
and then get a yes yeah and a
supplementary that if I if I may so the
intention here is to keep the bar open
as a sort of bar during the day in the
evenings and then from 7 o'clock or
whatever until 9:00 it becomes a
breakfast careful fielding food isn't
served at the moment except to the teams
we've got lots of teams that use that
and we do food for the teams and
breakfast will be served from 7 a.m. and
food will be there all day and on the
evening as well
obviously orbiting sundial inches the
local community as well as the people
that will be staying in their rooms
counselors any other questions thank you
very much indeed our next speaker
counselor
chairman and members of the West area
planning committee this planning
application was controversial from the
start
therefore my objections are on matters
of principle community concern and
location for the number of weeks rumors
were circulating at science and that
there was going to be alterations to the
Ulster members Club to be a change of
views to a bed-and-breakfast
establishment on hearing these rumors I
checked with the district council
planning office if there was a planning
application for the Austin members club
and was told no I asked this question a
couple of times after this with same
response when asked by residents about
the matter I responded that there were
no plans in place it was just rumors
I also reported this when asked that the
Ostertag claims for meetings on the 8th
of May I was in the Stratford District
Council Planning Office and asked the
question again I was told there was no
planning application in for all the
members club for a 31 bed
bed-and-breakfast establishment later
that day our received an email from the
Planning Office officers stating that
the plans were currently invalid work on
the building on both the internal and
external commenced during the month of
June this was reported to the
enforcement officer who visited the site
and informed the club manager and the
agent that if the work continued it will
be at the owners risk however work was
still taking place at the end of June so
he informed the enforcement officer
again who responded to me saying he had
received a number of complaints
regarding the ongoing work and that he
had written to to the agents confirming
what he had said earlier regarding
client's risk work clients risk work
ceased shortly after this with regard to
the location the members club is on the
edge of the Conway estate adjacent to a
children's play area and surrounded by
the orbiter own
caught Independent Living complex and
lives in close proximity to the oversea
house complex which has guaranteed
retirement home
the McCarthy stone retirement home which
has just opened through a retirement and
the recently completed creative care
properties for people with learning
difficulties and other health issues I
must admit that I'm disappointed that
the Town Council have withdrawn their
objection I have also had four telephone
calls from persons or believable
connected to the company asked in if I
am a keeper my objection in place and an
email from the agent asking if I was now
in a position to consider River though
removing my standing objection on the
application I did not remove my
objection for if I did my understanding
is that the application would have been
decided by officers delegated powers
which I felt would not be appropriate in
this case bearing in mind my concerns as
ward member and the concerns of the
local community and the changes it would
make for the immediate area chairman and
members these are the reasons I felt it
should come before you tonight for a
committee decision thank you
Thank You counselor any questions
councillors I have one if I may okay
well a couple interesting I don't know
this business or whatever I mean you're
obviously very close to it I mean what
what sort of functions has it been
holding I mean the the attention here
was thought it was claimed that the room
was going around functions were
cancelled I mean do you know how many
functions this workingmen's Club had
that I learned the case was I was a
wedding it was annoying that was
cancelled I know other other groups are
winning they're off it was something
like Taekwondo and things like that so
some regular season and I used to mentor
burn a couple of bingos there years ago
but it has changed since and I must
admit no I think they were and one
I'm too tight in three rooms for a
function I'm sure there was a banner
across the top okay so the impression
that it was still being used and just
the second one was your comment on 119
members sort of voting for for this to
be converted into what is effectively a
bar and a small hostel I don't know
where the under-19 members came from I
can't answer that because I don't know I
mean I'm just sitting here on behalf of
the community of Ulster who have
concerns about this and that is why I'm
doing what I'm doing
this is what I want it to be a committee
decision and not my decision because it
means such a lot to them
and I'm trying to be fair to them Thank
You Council that's very clear thank you
right
will will now move on to technical
questions councillors oh I've got one
can you put please the the floor plan
out that's it the proposed fourth one
yet this doesn't look like a bed and
breakfast to me it looks like a hotel
and I'm not sure whether there is a
difference in planning terms between a
bed-and-breakfast and a hotel in
planning okay that's fine councillor
carriage where's the kitchen
I'm just concerned that if you know off
from breakfast I'm sure there is from
what we've heard yes
actually just not quite convinced by the
applicants arguments you know is this
technical yes yeah car parking that's
what I was going for before I fell
asleep
is there enough car parking for this
number of rooms it has been assessed by
county highways you obviously assess it
in terms of its current use as the
members club and the difference in the
number of car parking spaces of it
change part changing used to the bed and
breakfast that's part of the proposals
they have obviously proposed to extend
the car parking slightly to the north of
the existing building and given the
amount of trip rates that would be
generated from a business and use of
this type but it was felt that the
number of car parking spaces was
acceptable in this case it strikes me as
a working men's club at the corner of an
estate will largely have people walking
to it but the driving to it especially
as their game editor in beer so I don't
see the trip roads would be incredibly
high at the moment so I'm going on 31
beds full occupancy how many car parking
spaces are there I think the point is
that yeah it probably is most people
would walk to it the existing situation
is that does a very large car parking
space anyway which is probably
underutilized but specifically for the
bed-and-breakfast use which would
obviously be the main people using cars
that's considered to be enough space
overall it probably would be able to
hire okay use rate than the current use
but there's enough on site to
accommodate that use if it helps cancer
I've just counted and it's 40 I see
there's some specifics about trees in
terms of soft landscaping are there any
more specific details about the other
boundary treatment and what's invisible
yes to the northern boundary between
where the children's play area is this
is proposed to be a hedgerow so new
hedgerow is currently a fence so that's
probably a hedgerow and then obviously
there's the main one is the tree
landscaping area to the corner of the
junction and then shrubs along the whole
of the areas adjacent to the highway and
also some further planting and
landscaping to that area which is
obviously felt to be a benefit over the
existing council Fielding I'm just
concerned because when we were being
briefed you refer to it as a small
kitchen is the kitchen
commercially big enough to to supply
both the bar and also the
bed-and-breakfast etc or are there
kitchens in the rooms and there's no
kitchens in rooms I couldn't accept that
councillor bombs the board members did
say that used to be a lot of news there
if you want cuz you can relate there was
Tom parking plan the implication was
that there wasn't as many dudes now what
I'm saying is no everybody would walk
would they um not everyone I mean there
was obviously quite considerable as you
can see from this is quite a large car
park and its existing use so obviously
depending on functions the type of
events that happening you know the car
park occupancy rate is going to go up
and down I haven't had any notification
about issues about overspill or anything
like that from historical records
okay fine oh just one final technical
point looking on this there are some
street lights here and one of the
conditions in the
in the aura report is that lysine would
be part of the conditions what would you
be proposing we're not proposing
anything at the moment there's nothing
shown it's if the applicant wishes to
have some external lighting they would
need to submit a scheme which we would
review but I would expect it to be quite
low-key just fine fine okay any other
questions no counselors let's open a
debate counselor Giles well so I do take
on board the concerns about the initial
lack of consultation and problems and
and as usual both counts the pain and
counsel areum's all they're not speaking
in her capacities accounts are always
put off to very much at the forefront of
their mind and speak and very active in
terms of speaking on behalf of the
community I have to say here I do
disagree with both of them I actually
find this proposal to be highly
innovative very entrepreneurial and
clearly a benefit in terms of helping
the this business which we have evidence
in the report requires diverse
diversification and I think using one
common sense and general knowledge one
would expect given changing
circumstances and markets it would
require that and I think this is an
excellent way to do it so I think the
idea that they will I actually think if
this is successful in the way that the
applicant has outlined and there's every
reason given that there are comparison
comparators to suggest it would be then
they would be potentially a very large
community benefit if this is open for
hot food it rejuvenates the the bar and
the pub area you've got then the
potential for that to be open to the
public and it to that to be a greater
community asset I also think there is a
large benefit in in some improvement to
this site so I would be happy to propose
this for grant but I what I would want
to see is a note that in relation to the
soft landscaping that the boundary
treatment is substantial and good
quality because I think this is a real
opportunity to improve this site
particularly
have a great you listed building in the
vicinity and that's if there is going to
be any external lighting and it may not
be necessary and that might be quite a
good thing that it definitely needs to
be sensitive as the officer said
sensitive Loki again bearing in mind the
presence of a listed building so that
would be the basis on which I would make
a proposal for grant Thank You Council
so that's a proposal with conditions I
mean with notes okay thank you
councillor Barnes yes I think it's a
wonderful initiative really look at it
we got to is really being used if you
wanted to use part of the whole you
could have a function and bed and
breakfast
I think it'll sign to club myself I'm
sorry that I don't agree with the board
member but far as I'm concerned you know
I'm quite happy to say it I think it'll
be an improvement and thank you we have
a proposal in a second I just like to
make one comment yeah I understand that
these businesses are struggling my view
here is the planning issue about whether
this is going to be a going concern it
is it is probably with not a planning
issue it sits down to commercial risk
from the the owner but it strikes me
that if they see successful at least the
bar will service the local population
and they'll have some well equal to go
rather than further afield so I'm quite
happy to support this so we have a
proposer and we have a seconder Thank
You councillor Fielding so the proposal
is to grant planning consent in
respective application ref 17 oblique
zero one one three three four all those
in favor
thank you very much indeed can search by
a two-minute break two-minute break
thank you
oh thank you very much indeed everybody
or just for the wait but it's all been
worth waiting for a short thank you the
next item on the agenda is 17 / 187 5/4
which is 61 ships and Road returning the
first sorry okay it's Eddie's going to
do the introductions Thank You chair the
application site is located when the
built-up area boundary of
stratford-upon-avon
and he's accessed off the ships term
road the western end of the site lies
within the conservation area and abuts
the tramway further to the west this is
an aerial photo of the site from the
west showing the surrounding build form
this plan shows the proposed layout of
the newly eleven dwellings which will
replace the single block of twelve flats
to the rib this slide shows the existing
and proposed elevations from the ship's
turn road this slide shows the rear of
the chipster Road building and the
proposed garage from the life's
committee the garage block did have a
flat up above it so that has been
reduced down inside and also hipped roof
added in addition to that the rear
decking area has been brought further
inwards so that finishes here
this shows the proposed elevations of
the Western buildings including that
from the tramway these are the front and
elephant of rear elevations of the three
dwellings at the center of the site this
varies from the ship's turn road and
shows the existing blocks a block of
flats in the center this photo shows the
location of the proposed access adjacent
to number 67 this photo shows the
existing access and number 61 a on the
right-hand side this is the rear of the
site with the existing garage as shown
on the right which also to be demolished
this shows the rear elevation of number
61 a the existing boundary wall which
would be retained and the existing
access in the background this is the
current view from the tramway this is
the view of the neighboring development
also from the tramway
finally this is another aerial view of
the site this time from the east showing
the ship's turn road at the front and
the tramway to the rear chairman the
recommendation is to grant permission
subjects the completion of the section
106 our 23 conditions are outlined on
page 86 thank you
thank you very much Eddie M just from my
members this was deferred previously and
for further information
Eddie can you just confirm that we have
received all that information and it is
now you're happy with that yeah
councillor Richards proposed the last
committee for details of the the raising
of the properties above the floodplain
and whether that was to the EI standard
since that time we have confirmed with
Environment Agency that the freeboard
safety margin of 600 millimeters is the
minimum they would require from the site
and that is what is proposed as part of
this development thank you thank you
our first to speak on this item is a
little mystic garlic Thank You mr.
garlic um you just explained you know
introduce yourself and then you'll have
three minutes in your own time
thank you I've never done this before so
I'll be up there with me a little bit of
course yeah I'll live as you can as you
can guess I have to live right opposite
this proposed development and I'd like
to object to it on on some of the on the
following grounds in my opinion it is
far too futuristic it doesn't blend in
at all with the surrounding properties a
number of the properties mine Lee the
ones are join in it 67 and 69 have been
very tastefully refurbished and the
gentleman the owner has made a good job
of them and the frontages of this
proposed development I feel it's my
opinion is that they should be of a
similar construction this whole
development whichever way you look at it
will stick out like a sore thumb
the height is also excessive I know it's
high name but I don't feel that this
should set a precedent for what's going
to go in the future the mixture
architecture on the ship stern road is
quite varied and I think that the
approach to the tang and some of them
leave a lot to be desired without
mentioning any names I don't think this
the ship Stern road approach I think
it's quite reasonable and I think that
this should be preserved
once this once these things have been
ruined like so many things in this town
it's done you can't undo it if you look
at this development
from the tramway walk it's it's over
it's overpowering totally overpowering
if you look at it on the other side
where it'd be Birds behind
Ashlee caught those I think they've been
they've been well done I don't think you
could make a much better job of them now
I have asked this is about the fourth
time and why this vehicular access has
been moved to the opposite side of the
plot ie from one side to the other and I
have yet to receive any response from
anyone whatsoever to explain why this
has been done and I should like to ask
this question
thirty seconds please that's why he
finished on that how do you apologize
didn't mean to interrupt you on that one
that is it yes you have your three
minutes have you heard any more to say
if your Ferguson where the where this
where that's all been moved up to the
other side is this access it's going to
be very close to the lady's property who
was here the last time she can't be here
tonight because she's in Warwick
hospital otherwise she probably would be
and I was talking to her husband the
other day and this this proposed
development is literally according to
him going to be a meter away from their
property and if you stand over their
front door and you see a huge brick wall
and the site's overpowering is the
biggest understatement of all times okay
I'll have to end you there I'm afraid
cathode jars so and I understand you
your principle objection is about the
the scale and the design of this
particular proposal and it's not in
keeping with what's that
but would you accept that it what is
proposed there is certainly an
improvement on what's there currently
this has been this line of argument this
comment has been stated to me by several
people and I'm sorry to say
that I find that comment is just not
sensible you could put anything there
you could put a warehouse there you
could you could put up an aircraft
hangar there it had looked better that
is not the point the point is to get
something right and do it right first
time because once it's done it's done
you can undo it and there's been so many
haven't welcomed taken earlier like
there's been that many planning
decisions made which like well luck a
lot of things to be honest with you okay
thank you any other questions just
reference the lady who objected
previously there's now withdrawn her
objection the Apollo I know that the
this flats been changed but I I said to
her husband I was standing talking to
him at the front at the front door and I
said you can see your boundary there and
this this wall and it's a big wall a
bare wall it's gonna move about probably
another four meters closer can't you
just stop for a few seconds and just the
envisage it because it's gonna affect
him not so much money but I still not
like to know the answer to this question
this is the why this access on the move
from there one particular point I will
ask that in their technical questions
all right thank you very much thank you
how gun alright our next speaker then is
there's nicholson and mike briggs &
Cootes
you have three minutes in your time
thank you back here again we did go away
from the last committee we did have a
serious think about ourselves about the
comments that were made at the last
committee sorry Eddie we have some
slides to share so I just wanted to draw
out some of the points that Eddie has
already told you about you can see the
changes there to the the garage we have
reduced that by taking the flat away and
that's brought a three point six meter
read option in the height of the garage
that you only raised a lot of concerns
with last time it's now at four point
four meters in height which is actually
less than one of the existing buildings
on the site which is five point five
meters and I know that figure came up a
lot last time here at committee so we're
now below the height of the existing
building and then if you could show the
second slide please
and this was just to draw out again the
changes that we've made at the back of
that nearest house 261 a so we've really
pulled that decking away it's just now a
series of steps to get into the back of
the house the screening is still there
obviously and the other change we've
made in terms of security is that the
gates between those two properties is an
exit only gate so people can't get into
the site that way they can only people
living there can come out which I know
was a concern to the neighbor and the
neighbor now having seen these not only
issue withdrawn the operation she
actually supports the scheme if you if
you look at the comments there is an
awful lot more I could say but I want to
give Mike time to talk about the
flooding which you know is it an issue
and how the water management solutions
have determined the height of those
buildings on the ships the road frontage
thanks Liz can we have the next slide
yes so the flood risk issues were
brought at last time and I just want to
confirm that the proposals do actually
meet they're in accordance with both
national planning and local planning
flood rates
issues the Environment Agency and the
lead local flood authority have reviewed
the proposals they given their approval
conditions essentially saying that we
actually do what we say we're going to
do references made last time to ashley
court and yep okay so yeah after court
which is nearby actually the way that
that was dealt with is fairly similar to
what we are proposing on our site we can
go into that in detail if required and
the next slide please the exception test
this is one of the key tests to do with
flood risk and on the left-hand side in
blue is the actual wording of the
exception test on the right-hand side of
the measures that we are proposing to
show that we have complied with this
exception test which is all about 30
seconds please
Thanks all that developing in flood
areas we've done a flood risk assessment
which is reviewed and approved by the EA
we've taken on board existing and future
conditions we've looked at the various
requirements in the exception test which
we meet there's no increase in flood
risk and there are various benefits on
flood risk so both the residents and the
neighbors to benefit from that thank you
thank you right members there any
questions that you would like to raise
cattle carriage is not particularly
relevant chair but just said of
politeness really could you remind us
why the entrance has been swapped from
one side to the other I know there was a
reason but I can't it was I don't know
that we talked about it that much last
time I think there's a number of reasons
one of the key ones was how vehicles
move within the site we get better
visibility splays onto the road if we
move the access you've got easier
turning circles within particularly for
emergency vehicles it makes it a lot
easier to create turning spaces for them
and then from that there's also view
straight through the site what we wanted
to get was a slight sight line straight
through that takes you down to the
tramway and
the area there so you get those linkages
between ships term road and the tramway
we felt in design terms that was quite
important I mean there are other issues
in terms of the cost of the flood
engineering works are very high so to do
it differently you'd have to start
dropping the number of units and then it
just stops being viable and so there
were quite a few reasons why it's moved
thank you very much councillor fielding
I asked the question last time to do
with why you had moved it and I was told
there was a power cable there was a long
could have been affected as you rather
change the story from what you told me
last time and and I still maintain
you've been better off leaving me the
question is why why have you sort of
changed the story from one thing to the
other no there is a power cable there
and there would be significant
earthworks involved if we had to move
that I think we went away from the last
committee and wanted to be able to
explain to you better why it has been
designed the way it is so it's it is
that power cable but it's the other
reasons with that and it's the
combination of costs but it's it's the
asset that it brings you you move the
buildings across but that creates these
views so design is an amalgamation of
all sorts of reasons that you put
together I just click on the previous
speakers said that the neutral buildings
don't blend in with a street scene would
you like to just comment on that if you
want a really detailed explanation I'll
end up bringing him Richard because he's
the architect but I supposed my planners
point of view would be there is no point
in just copying what you already have
we're here in the 21st century you were
building buildings for the future there
also has been a public consultation
exercise there were 500 leaflets put
through doors there were 40 or 50 people
turned up to the public consultation
exercise there was meetings with counter
the Ralph's councillor organ there was
quite a lot of work went into talking
about that
design it's going to come down to
whether you like it or not but if you
want more detail Richards here I like
that answers it for me thank you are
there any other questions members thank
you very much
um technical questions of Eddie any
technical questions no okay I don't know
cup two debate Casa Giles the neighbors
happy I'm happy I'm actually really
grateful to the applicant and the hard
work because it wasn't just a bit of a
response to the concerns it was a really
fulsome response and I think that's
really I think that's so pleasing
because often you'll get come back and
it's a little bit shaved off and they
how can we do the bare minimum to get
this through and actually that has been
a genuine worked at proposal to truly
meet the concerns expressed by the
neighbor and and I'm so happy that the
result is that that neighbors actively
supports this and I think this is now
also the opportunity to say that and
acknowledge that the expertise and hard
work that's been brought to bear on this
application means that this district is
able to use plots of land like this too
that are already in the built up area
boundary to fit a decent amount of
housing on that might otherwise go into
disuse because it becomes a flood risk
so there's a lot of hard work there's a
huge community benefit to being able to
use this land I do take on board the
objections and design is a very
subjective thing I am actually on the
very conservative with a small C end of
the scale when it comes to design and I
tend to be in a more traditional camp
but I there is a mix of stars on the
ship stern road and I equal take the
point in it just because something's an
improvement on what's there that it's
not a good reason to just okay it
through but I actually I actually do
think this is acceptable and I think it
will it's it's modern enough to provide
something new and innovative in it but
it's not too outrageous not to blend in
so for me I'm extremely happy with all
elements of the proposal thank you
I have to agree I think it's nice to see
the
the response that has been brought back
to this committee which has been
excellent so we're very pleased about
that echo that counts verb balance if
you want to talk it's on gotta be two
seconded I'm very pleased that they'd
listen and you know there was a great
amount of concern I know the board
members playing bridge against no she
was a bit surprised when I saw her but
I'm concerned it's it's better it's
helped everybody and members the vote
before you then we have a proposal we
have a second to the vote for use for
seventeen such a one eight seven five
such for all those in favor
thank you it's committee therefore
resource to grant planning permission
for 17/1 875 South all thank you very
much
the last item on the agenda this evening
thank you the last item on the agenda
Steve nning is 7901 oh seven to start
for chinois I presume that so correct
pronunciation Amy will tell me and over
to you
Thank You chairman the application site
stated by the black dot is a semi
detached dwelling on Middletown Lane
steadily within the West Midlands
Greenbelt the site situated south east
of Middletown named with open
countryside to the north so this slide
shows an aerial view of the application
site in relation to the neighboring
properties so the application proposes a
two-story side and rear extension with
the existing garage to be demolished
which is situated and slightly to the
rear of the property the two-story side
extension and rear extension would have
a Ridge height to match the existing
dwelling with an overall increase in the
built form of 84% materials would be
similar to those used in the existing
dwelling the proposed floor plans show
the extent of the increase in built form
to the side and the rear part of the
rear extension would be retained a
single-story the front of the property
is now being shown which as you can see
is mock tudor in design this image shows
the side in front of the property when
looking a southwesterly direction
towards the application site and finally
this image shows the separation distance
between the application site and the
adjoining property to the northeast so
there is one update on the update sheet
just to make you aware and chairman the
recommendation is to refuse the
application subject to the reasons which
are detailed within the committee report
thank you thank you very much our first
speaker is Keeley Thompson on behalf of
the applicant
clearly you have three minutes in your
own time thank you we've moved into our
dream home sorry we found our dream home
when we moved into the parish twelve
months ago as a Catholic family with
strong core values our main focus has
always been to provide our children with
a safe living environment to be proud of
we have settled in well since moving
into the parish and we have contributed
to the village greatly in terms of
donating the sign to the green dragon
public house which is at the heart of
the village and brings everyone together
however since submitting our planning
application in April we have been forced
on the roads of uncertainty given that
we are now several months on we've no
further developments
Andrew Watson came out to us we
discussed a compromise which we paid
another architect David Taylor of
Strafford District Council to resubmit
only to be then to be told to compromise
on a different area entirely the way
that we have been dealt with during the
process has caused some necessary pain
and suffering from the supporting
evidence I've provided there have been
several developments within the line on
a much bigger scale than what we are
proposing which have been approved
despite line within the green belt it is
based on the examples provided that we
consider our development has been taken
out of context when being referred to as
an appropriate development our proposal
lies within a developed area with no
consistent or uniform layouts with a
mixture of housing types and designs our
proposal is intended to maintain the
block proportions with the joining
semi-detached unit which has been
granted an extension larger than our
proposal furthermore the access Drive to
the left of our proposal maintains a
separation with the next block along
eliminating any compaction of the street
scene in addition we note that reference
has been made to the extension not being
designed to be subservient this was an
informed design decision this was to
reflect the attack neighbors extension
which does not take on the subservient
form it also maintains a continuous rich
line with no step-down by continuing
this theme through the overall built
form of the block would look original
and not draw the eye to untidy steps
within the row scape proving in keeping
with the street scene with the value too
with us sorry with a few to increase
value as new homeowners to the village
we are struggling to understand why we
have been met with such adversity both
ourselves and our architects are at a
loss as to why our proposal is being
recommended for a fusil when the
adjacent house next door has done the
very same thing got a larger scale the
reasons have not been outlined clearly
to us to give us anything definitive as
to why our project cannot proceed
we believe the treatment that we have
received is unfair and has led us to
research past improvisation district we
find our application being particularly
unfair that we are not able to create a
spacious home for our family yet others
have been granted that privilege within
the statutory period our feelings of
being victimized are further reinforced
as we have received the full support and
backing from our fellow neighbors with
no objections and no threat to the
environment and our proposal has been
well received by each of the five
members of sample and Parish Council who
fully support us in this game even prior
to the compromises which we were forced
to make spot-on three minutes absolutely
perfect and first thing I would like to
say I'm sorry that you feel you've been
messed about by the by the system that's
that's unfortunate and you shouldn't
really happen so these things do
unfortunately but I apologize on behalf
of the authority for that right members
our other any questions Council Johnson
Council
sure I did actually come into the
offices before two o'clock yesterday to
hand instant documentation I've then
received a phone call today to say that
the committee members hadn't received it
can I email it over and that had images
of the street scene of various different
houses with huge glass facades there was
also another image of a bungalow that
it's sort of had planning application
granted for a double storey extension
which had gone above the hedge line it's
a huge change as to what it was prior I
don't if you're not we saved it I don't
if sure okay can I just catch as I say
there have been some documentation from
yourself but they've been sent around
just clarify of the examples that have
been cited how a field application dated
or application references 13 slash a one
one eight full Hayden's application Oh
802 302 full and those are the two two
examples given both of those predate the
core strategy thank you no sorry
councillor Johnson asked my question
that's you it's okay as usual okay two
examples on this on Middleton Lane they
are yeah
yeah I just can't see them on the map
just wondering which
especially hey that's further down but
still on Middletown Lane okay I think
this would be something that we'd have
to reconsider in I don't know if it's
necessarily relevant to this particular
application because at the end of the
day we are looking at this application
not necessarily in relationship to
others
that's a playing process I'm afraid we
have to brother do you mind if I ask did
you receive about the bird's-eye view of
both properties our property would be
adjoining oh you've got that yeah and
any other questions Cal security hmm
just one how is your design gonna our
neighbor has had exactly the same
extension in fact we're actually coming
in three foot from the boundary line and
that's to keep the build square and not
offset so it's to keep the existing
boundary or square and next door have
actually gone out to the boundary line
and the idea of was proposing to keep
the ridge line straight was to follow
through and keep a sympathetic view when
looking at the property from the street
scene and both neighbors either side of
fully supported off that along with the
five members of the parish can't so
they've got no issues whatsoever with
the overall design impact or any
harmfulness to the Greenbelt there's
nothing but all no objections of caring
about that
we've in fact track to the traces the
planning permission for the other half
of the property double bed double garage
with bedroom Ava approved 19th of April
1979 so it's it's a very old extension
very old application fine that's okay
all right thank you very much lovely
thank you
council Wright isn't here so technical
questions so is I'm looking at this
birds it's quite helpful this photo this
okay it's not being proposed largely
going to look similar to what is going
on in that neighboring property sort of
to mirror it or is it got additional
bits at the back hall okay so as you can
see from this photo and by comparison to
next door and the application site
extension will go around the rear at two
storey level with a single storey
extension as well and which is there in
current form and so you can see the
difference between the two properties
quite clearly in that image yeah it
links around to the rear from the side
in terms of the size obviously this is
that the major concern here we're
obviously removing a rather unattractive
garage at the rear which is very
sizeable double garage er we're
replacing it I mean have you factored in
the fact that you're getting rid of a
rather big garage and putting a smaller
one in or or doesn't that apply as my
question
okay and unfortunately I am not the case
officer that's dealt with the
application and throughout the process
and from reading the report and I'm not
quite clear whether or not the garbage
has been included within the assessment
and obviously in green about terms we
would consider built form on the site
and it would be within a reasonable
proximity from the existing dwelling so
unfortunately I can't quite clarify an
inverter on that and but from looking at
the size of the extension and my opinion
would be that I don't think it would
offset it and would still result in a
disproportionate addition okay well
thanks Casa fielding first income is
that is there a gap between the side of
the house and leaf the hedge for taking
stuff down between the two properties
I mean pursue the back of the property
so I think I think I think following you
so there will be a small gap left
between the existing boundary treatment
as you can see the gap will be reduced
and quite largely and however between
the application site and next door there
is a sort of access path which I Oshin
goes further down into the field so so
there would be significant gap between
the properties to consider they wouldn't
have an impact from a street sure that
was the question the question was a gap
down the side of the house and their
boundary things like for example wheelie
bins and an access down the side of the
property sorry
and I I misunderstood what you were
saying and so obviously there would be
limited gap as you can see to the rear
of the property and from the drawings it
would show that would be difficult to
get but we've been down the side of the
property however given the set back from
the road that's not to say
that there isn't sufficient space to the
front of the property for refuse bins to
be stored stored to the front of the
property and with regards to obviously
other items that would be more difficult
so I can't obviously speak on behalf of
the applicant as to what their
intentions are Jones so on the front of
the committee report it says third party
response is one less received a concern
about impact on the living room window
am i right in assuming that comes into
the house because I can't but it can't
be the other side
[Music]
unfortunately I'm not sure which
property it refers to and that within
the offices report it is stated that the
development does not infringe upon any
45 25 degree lines from the center of
neighboring habitable room windows of
the adjoining property and I take from
that looking at this plan there is no
window on the ground floor side that
would look into that anyway well no I
mean there's a big gap anyway I'm not
I'm just sort of really covering all
bases here but so from let's go to the
elevations that's probably the easiest
point of view so there would be two side
windows at first and ground-floor which
would look in a westerly direction
towards Tudor house from having a look
at the floor plans and one of those the
ground floor would serve a breakfast
kitchen room and the first floor would
serve an ensuite which you would
normally assume would be obstacle glazed
or conditioned to ensure that is
obstacle glazed polities chairman just
just number this seems again to be the
size just so I'm clear our new core
strategy or where you're citing cs10 and
cs20 when you're looking at the
next-door neighbor and that was in 1979
that was obviously under a different
strategy could anybody know whether
there is a material difference or what
in 79 we are going back to the old 30%
rule that might be a bit tough hazarding
a guess I suspect the 30% rule with
supplying because that would have been
79 89 mm that's what 30 30 28 years ago
so I I'm old enough to remember that
sadly okay thank you
I shall open up for debate Kathy Jones
okay I definitely disagree with the
second reason for refusal on here which
is about thing extensions being an
appropriate scale and SEP servant
because I think the applicant has given
a very good reason and justification as
to why you wouldn't have a subservient
extension here and I think that makes
the entire sense looking at what's been
done with the neighbor and I think it's
exactly right to say if you were going
to build an extension you'd want it to
be all one thing and equally I don't
think so putting aside from the
Greenbelt perspective I don't think
there is anything inherently
disproportionate about that extension so
I just don't agree with reason 2 so in
terms of reason reason one the green
boat obviously is an important
consideration and for me it's quite
finely balanced however I would be
minded in favor of actually granting
this on the basis that I think I agree
with them counsel Orton's observation I
do actually think removal of that garage
particularly given it the nature of it
in its design would be a significant
benefit not just because of the size of
the garage but also because of the
design and look of the garage and I I
actually think here it is a it is false
to fail to consider what has gone on
with the neighbor now yes it happened in
a different era it happened before these
policies and we must judge this
application in accordance with current
policy but on the other hand it can't be
right to completely ignore the context
in which this is proposed and so I think
taking all of those things into account
for me on these specific circumstances
and bear in mind the mitigation of
getting rid of that garage I don't
consider this to be a disproportionate
addition on these very particular
circumstances so as long as there are
appropriate conditions that the planning
officers were satisfied with including
the obscure glazing of the ensuite
bathroom on the top floor then I would
be happy with a grant of this thank you
if you could go back to the floor plans
please thank you very much
get up it is the quantum here and if
this was before us and we're the new
breakfast kitchen is proposed just an
extension of that area I don't think
we'd have any issue the thing is we've
got a dining room and a bedroom one over
the top it is a big extension I would
prefer that the bedroom over the top
wasn't there because I'm pretty if that
was granted with a breakfast kitchen I'm
pretty sure that that dining room could
be built at single-story under
prescriptive rights so we're talking
about that extra bedroom I would agree
with councillor jars that I think the
quantum is diminished by the about by
the loss of the garage and I just
although it is a big building I don't
think it's disproportionate and I don't
think we're going against cs10 by going
against the officers recommendation in
this particular interest or this
particular case so again I would be
happy to propose if I could find a
seconder that we grant consent to this
application
counseling I'm quite happy to go along
with the other two my only concern is
that gap between the hedge in the house
for getting materials down beside on
this income summary over the landowner
who has the right of way on the thank
you first thing I need to have a real
hard think about this one
Karajan says that she doesn't agree with
number two on this one first of all
saying what you're saying to me is you
do not consider this to be overly large
no the green in the context of Greenbelt
there's a question about it but if
imagine this wasn't green boat because
yeah I agree that but the reason one is
considering the green at boat aspect but
reason 2 is our general policy about
extensions being subservient and of an
appropriate scale and what I'm saying is
actually yeah I think this is an
appropriate scale and I think there's a
good reason why it shouldn't be
subservient so that's why I'm saying I
disagree with reason to personally
and the other one is if you are going to
propose this or any anyone is going to
propose it then we have our special
circumstances for approval of this
within the green belt so it's a it's a
it's an exception to the green boat rule
as long as we don't consider it to be a
disproportionate addition and I think my
reasoning is on these particular facts
in this particular location bearing in
mind the modification to the neighboring
property and the demolition of the
garage
and the fact that there is already a
rear extension I think on balance on
fine balance this isn't a
disproportionate extension anyone else
want to speak on this because I I can't
go along with that I'm afraid because
looking at it I think it is a large
extension I think it fills the plot and
we have refused numerous applications
recently including the one that came
before us this evening kidding - Road
for filling the plot right across its
width and again that says to me that it
is too large for its plot this pinning
the pinning the plot with that I still
say it is overly large and I agree with
us the argument on some sodium's that is
a that is something else I know we have
a policy on that and it is something we
can actually override if we so desire
and if for example we did on on an
instructor not that long ago where the
majority of the houses work subservient
and it would look silly that one had
been so we can take a judgment on that
and that's what we can do so in that
particular context I have known no major
problems but I don't add I can't agree I
still think it is overly large okay I
just been asked to say Karen do you feel
it is small scale then
if I come first the failure to the
committee report impact on neighbor then
I saw it destroyed by conclusion the
Greenbelt increase of 84 percent over
the existing dwelling turning to policy
cs10 category B a small-scale extension
or alteration of a building or the
replacement of an existing building of
the same use as long as the replacement
building or exchange and I take that to
employ extension as well is not
materially larger than the one it
replaces so the issue is whether it is
materially larger now the offices
assessment is an 84% increase extension
increase over and above the existing
does constitute is in conflict with that
policy because it is materially larger
and therefore does not constitute small
scale in which case if you are looking
to approve it you would need very
special circumstances and the offices
report does specify that none have been
put forward so there is no justification
put forward to override the Greenbelt
policy pretty sure that the the test is
is it a small scale extension if it
isn't small scale and we're told it's an
84% increase then you have to show very
special circumstances coach yes by the
time thank you chair I'm sorry but I've
been I've had my hand up for a while
we've had a lengthy explanation another
explanation before I got it
sorry chair I was just getting a bit
angry I've just read cs10 again okay I
doubt I find myself unusually
disagreeing with officer on a matter of
actual policy and that's unusual because
I have been told it's my understanding
that
a small stove extension of a building is
acceptable we've got that small scope
you go to the explanation right the
explanation for point one to the
extension or alteration of a building
provided that it does not result in
disproportionate additions over and
above the size of the original building
it there's nothing about material a
material increase that's if you're
rebuilding it but if you're just
extending and of course it's going to be
materially bigger
that's it cannot be so the materially
bigger bit is for a rebuild okay the
small scale which is what we're saying
it is is for an extension I can't accept
that you can have a any kind of
extension which isn't materially larger
than what you're extending I mean it's
just impossible so I think we've got to
ignore this materially larger bit and go
with the words here is it
disproportionate yeah and we don't think
it's disproportionate so we do not need
very special circumstances just to
repeat the test in the policy is his
small scale so members need to decide
whether it was a small scale extension
or not councilor carriage right when he
says the explanation ie the definition
of small scale is one has to consider
whether it's disproportionate I'm not
sure that small scale is defined Karen
no I I'm not aware of any any specific
definition of Sportsgirl
it's about I think it's a matter of
planning judgment what small scale is
but there is an explanation in our
policy that explains it it might not
define it but it explains it on page 70
of our four point one toy to put it
point three yeah Viet the extension or
alteration of a building provided that
it does not result in disproportionate
additions over and above the size of the
original building full stop yeah I mean
I think the wording of the policy is
small scale and that and that's the
policy and clearly that explanation is
there to help guide your planning
judgment it's a small scale and
disproportionate kind of very similar
questions again I completely agree with
cats as Charles and carriage it's all
about proportion this is actually quite
a small house and it's actually having
an extension which is 84 percent brick
looking it from my judgment and have to
use old money on the faith it's about
700 750 feet that's not a large
extension
it's just large proportion and when you
consider to what what is what it's being
a joined to I mean a large extension is
taking three thousand square feet and
you've got a thousand square feet I just
don't think turning a three-bedroom
detached water so terraced house into a
four-bedroom terraced houses is is
overdevelopment I'm gonna stop it just
carry on one more point and then I'll
take one more question and that's it
okay
yes thank you - yes I do stand corrected
in terms of the
what I would do Wow what I would refer
you to is page 72 the policy which is in
block development management
considerations an extension to a
dwelling must not result in a building
disproportionately larger compared with
the original building the a replacement
building must not be materially larger
but I think the first part of that
sentence is the critical part in terms
of your assessment and so one of the
reasons I don't think it's
disproportionate is when it's viewed in
the context of its neighbor and secondly
yes filling the plot would usually be
problematic and that's usually something
that would not be in keeping but again
the neighbors feels the plot you know
the reason it's not accepted in other
places is because we see lots of gaps
and then someone wants to cram their
plot whereas here this is in context and
that's the reason I'm happy that it's
proportionate right I think we're gonna
end the debate on that point thank you
very much indeed everybody a lively
debate I think did I get a proposal
counsel Lawton do I have a seconder on
that yeah the the vote before you is to
grant planning permission for 1700 107
to slash for all those in favor without
a second before we vote with the
conditions and also are we happy with
the yes we are happy with the view of
the Committee on this one
okay so again I say all those in favor
of granting plan permission against this
committee therefore resolved to grab
plan information for 1701 Oh 7-pole to
such fault thank you very much Lee
that's the end of the meeting that's the
end of the meeting and I have yet to do
the minutes but Oh